good morning everybody we'll get started
sorry a couple of minutes late
uh
being 9 41 i'm gonna open the public
hearing on house bill 1160 relative to
obedience to signals at railroad
crossings
uh prime sponsor representative o'brien
welcome back to transportation sir
thank you mr chairman it's uh good to
see some old familiar faces and
good to see some new ones here but uh as
some of you know i was uh acting chair
and vice chair of this committee several
years back and had a lot of fun with
transportation you guys are the movers
and shakers of the state so very much
excuse me it's uh
i bring this up bill 1160 relative to
obedience to signals at railroad
crossings i bring this on behalf of the
railroad workers
mainly the
their work in the state the brotherhood
and maintenance of way
the equipment
that is used today to maintain
tracks and stuff like that is quite
large my background came from
firefighting i was a deputy chief in the
city of nashua and even though
firefighting is one of the listed as one
of the more hazardous type of jobs that
people work does not mean that we ignore
safety you know we try to do everything
within our power to increase the safety
and this is what clearly is the
intention of this bill
if we look at it it basically just say
uh everybody seems to agree that if a
train is approaching a crossing or
something like that to yield to the
train those of us that do have any spots
where the would act accordingly
but what about the workers that go to
maintain and again like i stated before
that some of this equipment is
relatively large
so this will accept uh will make it more
safe for the maintenance people who are
take care of our tracks
now in looking at what we brought up
this bill uh
you know the road perdition is always
not paved in gold but
in looking at this and discussing with
other concerns of other
stakeholders
let's take a look at line three of the
bill
this is the first mentioned other
on-track equipment and that includes
that the apparatus that the railroad
workers would be using
and as you know recreational within the
state of new hampshire such as up in
laconia for example they do have those
little push cuts and stuff like that and
clearly this bill is not intended to
cover those particular
vehicles
so therefore
i will offer to write or if the
committee would like to write an
amendment
and i think i have somebody who might
volunteer to assist with that
representative teleski if she shall
see fit
is basically just put in
in the example of line three it would
read would be maintenance of way so line
three would be obedient obedience to
signal indicating approach of a train or
other maintenance of way on track
equipment and that would clearly
designate what the bill uh intends to do
is to uh
protect the railroad workers that are
you know doing the track and that's it
mr chairman i of course be open for
questions but also with me
and to present this bill
if you should call would like to call is
mr darren gordon
vice president of the local lodge 201 of
the brotherhood and maintenance of way
workers
thank you representative any questions
from the committee representative gorski
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative for your testimony quick
question um in terms of these
maintenance of vehicles you mentioned
they were large i mean how large are
they the size of a box car can you give
us some indication of that well that's
interesting and i not to be repetitive i
think you will hear in later testimony
but i was surprised this morning that
some of them are way more than an empty
box cop but i'll let the experts uh
that's a good question and then that's
part of the concern of safety with this
thank you
further questions representative o'hara
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative so when you step in
laconia you're talking about the push
carts you're talking about the pedal
bikes too this wouldn't be covered under
that that's correct i mean the
intentions the sole intention of this
bill is the protector uh to protect the
railroad workers nothing to do with the
recreational end of it you know
that track i think could be further
explained by uh representative
d.o.t that is here if they wish to
testify but basically that's uh
the state regulates that this is mostly
just for the workers within the railroad
industry
further questions
representation
thank you thank you mr chairman thank
you representative brian for taking the
question on these um on-track
maintenance vehicles if you will
do they set off the signal on crossings
where there are
you know signal indicators and gates do
they they will trip them the same way a
train would
first let me welcome back today to
transportation again yourself thank you
but
uh that's a good question but i'm not of
expertise i think uh mr gordon if
allowed to testify could clearly explain
if that trips that uh safety device
thanks
further questions from the committee
seeing none thank you thank you mr
chairman good to see you again and thank
you for the warm welcome same here
um chair recognizes darren gordon
in support of the bill
uh good morning chairman walsh
and vice chairman gagne as a member of
the committee thank you for the
opportunity to testify before you today
on an important public safety issue for
motorists pedestrians and the men and
women who work on our railroad tracks in
new hampshire and throughout the country
i am darren gordon
i am the vice president of local lodge
201 out of derry new hampshire and with
me is maddie zuzak who is also the
secretary treasurer of 201
um we are here to offer you a strong
support for this house bill 1160 that
would amend rsa
265.48 to include maintenance of way
equipment
under the current new hampshire law
maintenance of way railroad contractors
and other on-track equipment are not
included in the prohibition concerning a
motorist's responsibility when
approaching the crossing
it is critically important that when the
gates go down or when that there are
train approaching or a flagment or a
stop sign exec
present the motor vehicle will stop a
safe distance from the crossing
house bill 1160 would update existing
railroad crossing laws pertaining to
motorist responsibility at railroad
crossings
currently maintenance of way
railroad contractors and other on-track
equipment are not included in the state
statute that mandates motorist
responsibility when approaching a
crossing
the issue is on track maintenance
equipment has evolved into train-like
machines that present the same dangers
of a train slash engine with cars not
being able to stop on a dime
through modernization of railroad track
equipment our members now operate
state-of-the-art equipment on tracks in
new hampshire
with that comes size we are long gone
from the days when push carts ran up and
down the tracks
while most public understands trains
occupy the tracks in their respective
neighborhoods and to avoid them at all
costs not everybody is aware of the
on-track equipment and construction
machines that travel on track
infrastructure in new hampshire and and
around the country
this is a true safety bill that would
help protect new hampshire motorists and
our members that work and live in new
hampshire
similar legislation has already been
passed in over 34 states including
alabama arkansas california colorado
connecticut delaware georgia idaho
illinois
and others and there is currently active
or pending legislation in eight states
the legislation is supported by rail
labor and the railroads themselves
railroad contractors and in fact i have
no found no public opposition
it will help to clarify that
there are other pieces of equipment that
travel on the tracks
that present the same dangers to
motorists as trains
also we like to help the educate the
public on this fact after the state
statute is amended
working with the new hampshire operation
lifesaver and railroads look listen and
live psa programs
thank you for the opportunity to testify
thank you for your testimony any
questions from the committee
representative erosion i think it's a
follow-up
thank you mr chair thank you mr gordon
for taking the question it's a follow-up
to what i asked representative regard to
whether or not this equipment will trip
off the signal and gate and um and
another piece of that is are these lit
and have loud horns or whistles like a
train does to um
so their presence is is known in another
way that's kind of the question
okay so according to our operating rule
um that we use all of our on-track
equipment has to have lights
uh forward and back flashing lights or
strobes horns
and all the other appropriate audible
safety devices
and some of the equipment if it's
designed to will set off the signals
reliably and then we have equipment that
we insulate purposely to not set off the
signals
further questions from the committee
representative gorsky thank you mr
chairman this is a follow-up and thank
you mr gordon for taking my my question
um he mentioned the representative
mentioned the side he's a big size
equipment and you kind of mentioned
they're like train-like machines can you
give us a sense of the size
of some of these maintenance of way
equipment
yes so we have um a crew what's called a
surface crew and their job is to line
and level the tracks
the lightest machine in that is called a
ballast regulator and it averages about
50 000 pounds
the heavier end of the machines
is called a vibrating stabilizer
and those average between 96 and 100 000
pounds
thank you
further questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much
did you have written testimony or not
i do if you can pass one up to the clerk
that'd be appreciated
uh anybody else wish to speak on house
bill 1160.
i neglected to mention it before but if
you'd like to sign in either for or
against the bill the blue sheets are out
back
seeing nobody else signed up to speak
i'm going to close the public hearing on
house bill 1160.
i'll open the bill for how i'll open a
session for house bill 1239 fn relative
to virtual offender hearings
and they will be
thank you
i knew it was going to be you anyway
and when representative walsh is ready
and he will introduce the bill
thank you for your efficiency mr chair
uh for the record my name is tom walsh
i'm a representative from the town of
hooksett
um and i'm here to introduce house bill
um
this is one of three bills that i
introduced at a request of uh former
director belecki from the department of
motor vehicles
uh the major part of the bill this
changes and i do understand both sides
of this issue
is it changes uh
notification to first-class mail uh if
if you are
considered
being a habitual offender
um
instead of me getting into the details
of it again i introduced this for a
courtesy i know there are people on both
sides of this issue behind me that can
do a much better job explaining the
issue it's not the first time we've seen
this here
but after having a meeting with
department of safety i figured it was
worth having us talk about it one more
time so
with that
thank you mr chair
thank you representative
next up we have
paul
halvorsen
merrimack county attorney
good morning in
opposition oh sorry about that
good morning i'm paul halverson i'm your
merrimack county attorney
and uh i'm here to oppose the bill as
it's currently written
uh i want to give a little background uh
to
the ho statute
and compare it to some difficulties that
were encountered
when
with an operating after suspension
statute
mental state changed to knowingly
the original declaration of policy that
the legislature put out and it's
outlined in the habitual offender
statute
addresses
providing maximum safety for all persons
who travel or otherwise use the ways of
the state
and to deny the privilege of driving
motor vehicles to persons who utter
conduct have demonstrated their
indifference for the safety and welfare
of others and of disrespect for the laws
of the state the orders of the court and
the acts of administrative agencies and
that's under rsa 262-18
and
back in
the court
by a
by a case and i'll reference it by name
state versus crotty
put a mental state of knowingly onto the
offense of operating a vehicle after
being certified as a habitual offender
the mental state knowingly is very
important because it requires notice to
the individual
several years ago the court did a
similar action
with the operating after suspension
statute
and i can tell you that the oas statute
was very difficult to prosecute after
the
uh legislate i'm sorry after the courts
issued their orders saying that it
requires a knowingly mental state
uh
absent
a in-hand notice
uh there was it's very difficult to show
that someone knew about their status
when their license was suspended the
same applies to habitual offender status
there were many many cases
of operating after suspension that could
not go forward
should this
change to allow by male
notice to the individuals go into effect
the same issual crop up and prosecution
of both misdemeanors and felony habitual
offender issues
the
the impact of this as it's written
would be to allow for an individual who
has a bad record who is somewhat
responsible who goes to his hearings and
gets certified as an ho and later drives
to actually be held more accountable
than the individual who blows off his
hearing says he didn't get notice drives
and is caught afterwards
and i think that as a matter of public
policy sends a bad message
i've talked to several other county
attorneys in recent days
the ones that i spoke to and exchanged
email with
agree with my analysis
there are two other
local
prosecutors in uh franklin allenstown
who emailed me the this morning
indicating they had the same concern
for
um for this uh happening in the local
courts for a misdemeanor habitual
offender uh if this law is enacted as
it's written
uh i'm not going to comment as to
whether or not
amendments could make the law work
beyond saying
that
the issue is one of
of notice
what address do they use to send notice
it's not outlined in a statute is it
sent by registered mail what happens if
they deny
service of the registered mail what
happens if they don't keep their address
updated on motor vehicle records as
required by by statute
all of that factors into whether or not
the person has actual notice of their
status as a mutual offender and will
affect the prosecution
so that's the opposition in a nutshell
it would be very difficult to prosecute
these cases should this go into effect
as as written i'll gladly entertain any
questions that anyone may have
any questions from the committee
representative thank you mr chair thank
you for taking my question sorry i'll
stretch
um just can you please clarify just so i
completely understand how the process is
done now it's physically someone handing
an offender an envelope
my understanding is that when the person
is certified at their certification
hearing
the notification to them is at that
hearing the minute they're certified
they're they're notified of it um
if mr caskel behind me testifies he can
elaborate more on the current process
that's an administrative process that
that i'm not deeply involved in but my
understanding is that as of right now
they are informed the minute the hearing
examiner
issues their
their decision
at the hearing they're they're given
notice right then and there i believe
the orders read to them there too
quick follow-up sure is there anything
if this bill were to pass that would
prevent that same
procedure
well i think
in part yes
if the bill passes as it's written if a
person doesn't appear
the
then they would be they would be
certified
i believe
without their appearance and if they're
certified without their appearance the
issue becomes one of knowledge if they
later drive they may receive notice for
a hearing and notice to come to a
hearing but they would not be informed
of the of this of the suspension to date
the suspension goes into effect uh
they'd miss their their opportunity for
for a due process hearing
and if it goes out by first class mail
the notice of the hearing the question
becomes did they actually receive that
notice that's what it all boils down to
notice to the individual i can say that
i i guess i will address
a possible way of fixing this uh within
the bill if there was some sort of
follow-on
um
in-hand notice if they fail to appear at
their certification hearing uh that
could be a fix but but that is a minor
uh one of the
one of the several fixes uh that would
need to happen in my opinion
to make the bill workable uh the address
issue which addresses it sent to would
have to be fleshed out
and
whether or not the suspension would go
into effect prior to their notice as a
habitual offender
much like dwi statute if an individual
has a
conviction on a dwi the license loss
goes into effect
even if they appeal their their
their dwi for example a dwi
second offense that has a mandatory jail
sentence they can appeal their dwi but
under statute the license law still goes
in into effect
and and
i think something like that here would
would be appropriate but as i said i
don't think as written you can
incorporate those type of changes easily
within this statute as it's currently
written thank
you perhaps gorski did you have a
question
i was already answered for the question
thank you thank you
representative hill
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question yes sir um
do i understand you right that that um
you think this is a solution in search
of a problem or
um is this also something that you could
discuss with the director
uh directly and and talk about uh
possible solutions if there is a problem
frankly i don't know what brought rise
to the
uh i was not proven to the conversations
that brought rise to to recommend to the
proposed
legislation um if there's a cost-saving
measure to be gained by the department
of safety i fully understand that
but that becomes a public policy issue
for the legislative bodies to make a
determination on whether or not they
want to accept
the added cost for department of safety
to have notice to individuals
and
or
eliminate some of the cost and risk a
basically in my opinion
going against the public the stated
public policy that's within the habitual
offender statute then that's a
legislative choice and i'm not gonna i'm
not gonna comment about that
sure
um do you think it would be possible for
uh the county attorneys to
group together and and maybe make a
recommendation
for a possible solution
i could ask the
the the the county attorney group but
we're kind of reluctant my opinion i'm
reluctant to recommend
um
proposed legislation wording to to the
legislative body i think there's a
separation of powers issued error my
personal opinion i don't think we should
get into the writing we can certainly
comment on on on on items such as i'm
doing now the impact of items but i
don't think my opinion i don't think i
should be involved in in
proposed a wording of a of a statute
beyond saying what i think may help
um like in my question a moment ago
beyond that i don't think
i would be involved other county
attorneys i can ask the question though
any other questions from the committee
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you
chris casco department of safety welcome
been a long time
yes good morning thank you
vice chair gagne members of the
committee my name is christopher casco
i'm the administrator of the bureau of
hearings as well as prosecution for the
department of safety appearing before
you today in support of house bill 1239
and it's my office the bureau of
hearings that holds the habitual
offender certification hearings and this
is something the process for the
hearings we've been discussing at the
department of safety at least for the
last decade or so
we've done two lean process events
looking from start to finish at the
process and trying to find ways to make
it better
really the primary motivation for this
as i see it is to expedite the process
so that high risk drivers are removed
from the roadways more quickly
and to go way back into the history of
this at one time the superior courts
did the habitual offender certification
hearings
that then was transitioned to come under
the department of safety and give the
director of motor vehicles the authority
to do the complete process from the time
someone qualifies as an habitual
offender up through the entire hearing
process and it's a requirement under our
administrative rules
that the order to appear
which is the hearing notice with a
certified copy of the driving record
must be served in hands
on the habitual offender
subject
by a law enforcement officer so it's
been done by state police for a long
time so to start the hearing process in
terms of the notice to the individual
that must be served in hand by state
police so that process
becomes lengthy
and at one of the
the lean events there was a power point
and there were a couple of different
ways the procedure was
described through different boxes and
steps in the process in the current
process that we have now that requires
in-hand service had something like 30
different boxes
from the process starting with our
office where one of our attorneys looks
at the record decides who qualifies
we have support staff who prepares the
order to appear in the driving record
essentially what we call the ho packet
which then would go to state police it
would be assigned to a trooper
now it's troopers at troop g
who have that responsibility so the
packet would go from our office after
several steps to troop g to a trooper
who would have to find the person at
their home
at their place of business and serve the
paperwork in hand for the person to come
back for the hearing as a result of the
first lien event we came up with a new
process
by which we would send out an initial
letter to every habitual offender
subject inviting them to voluntarily
come into our office
and
to be served in hand by a trooper so we
started that process
right now we do it every other tuesday
at one o'clock so what we do is we send
out 25 letters
so the first 25 people were trying to
initiate the process with inviting them
to voluntarily come into our office we
have a trooper from troop g right now
it's a retired sergeant who comes in
every other tuesday and whoever appears
out of the 25 letters they get served
their hearing paperwork and they can
choose to have their hearing that day or
they can come back at a later date so
we've been doing that kind of revised
process as an internal solution
to the issue of the long periods of time
that it takes to get someone in for one
of these hearings
and that has reduced time for some of
the people for those that choose to come
in
based on an involuntary invitation
based on the numbers we've seen while
we've done that process we get about
half
on a good day maybe a little more than
half out of the first time we resumed
the voluntary service tuesdays we got 13
out of 25 which wasn't bad unfortunately
like many things during covid19
we weren't doing any
of the voluntary service on those
tuesdays everything was going out to
state police for in-hand service
and just
the
benefit for the person really it's not
helpful to a person for this process to
be a long one before they come in for
these certification hearings because
habitual offender is is based on a
number and type of conviction within
five years major convictions for
habitual offender are driving under the
influence disobeying a police officer
driving after suspension
most habitual offenders have at least
one major there are some minors and
there are different combinations that i
don't really need to get into
but
for a lot of habitual offenders they're
already under suspension for another
reason it's typical they're under
suspension for a dwi
so they're serving a court suspension
some cases or in fact a lot of cases
because of the enhanced service
requirement it delays the time between
when they qualify for habitual offender
until they get to our office
for one of our hearings examiners to do
the certification and to do what may be
a separate license suspension it's a
mandatory suspension for
habitual offender but for someone who
was already under suspension and who has
been under suspension ever since the
last conviction that's causing habitual
offender the hearings examiner can date
the licensed suspension back to the
court date so for the person if they can
serve or at least begin serving this
habitual offender minimum one year
suspension
effective on the date of the court
hearing they're better off they've got
time served they can then be decertified
sooner than if
years go by and we see this happen
the trooper's not able to serve someone
several years go by
kind of these unable to serve paperworks
just sit and not a lot happens with them
after the trooper makes three attempts
to serve
they kind of go in a drawer and where it
catches up with the person is when they
seek restoration of their license
they're at the dmv
then we're trying to then serve while
that adds layers of process so really
the first rationale behind this is to to
have the process go much more quickly so
rather than having an enhanced service
we would send out that hearing notice
and the driver record
by first class mail to the address of
record and the license holder is
obligated to
have an updated address with the
department of motor vehicles and when
they move to do within a certain period
of time so essentially this this would
put some burden back on the license
holder where it should be because a
license is a privilege that is something
that was recognized
during our studies of this issue is that
it's the responsibility of the license
holder to a large degree
to do what they're supposed to do and to
to let the dmv know what their address
is so that proceedings like this can be
commenced more simply and easily for the
citizen as well as for
the department of safety this also will
give citizens
a certainty of result of what the final
license suspension term is if this
habitual offender hearing is hanging out
there unresolved
a lot of people they don't understand
they think they're serving their
suspension already they're thinking it's
an automatic process after they went to
the court they don't understand that
it's a fairly complicated process within
hand service that's required for them to
resolve their case so this will allow
more people to serve their license
suspension time concurrently where the
law allows it also it's an embarrassment
for someone to have a trooper knock on
their door and serve paperwork
for a licensed suspension issue so this
will eliminate that and one thing that
was alluded to when one of these studies
at the department of safety was having
increased law enforcement contacts may
not be a good thing it could be an
officer safety type issue having these
contacts just for
a simple procedure of serving paperwork
although i'm not sure i've never heard
of any incident happening
during an enhanced service lieutenant
o'leary from troop g is here present if
the committee has any questions for him
we're trying to expedite our testimony
by having me be the the spokesperson for
all of the issues
and then just
having a much more expeditious
administrative process this bill
will allow us to do it
and there are some other states we have
looked at that allow for mailing of
habitual offender either pay hearing
paperwork or suspension notices vermont
maine and massachusetts all allow for
first-class mailing of some of this
habitual offender either suspension
notice
or
hearing
paperwork so those are the reasons why
we're in favor of this it's something
we've been looking at for a long time
and decided that legislation was the
answer rather than going to
jalcar to amend the administrative rule
we figured this was the preferable
procedure and i did talk at length with
attorney halverson because to put on my
prosecutor hat i supervise department of
safety prosecutors and i understand the
concern
with
a habitual offender certification that
will be based on a mailed
notice of the hearing
so there will be people that fail to
appear in response to the mailed hearing
notice
and this bill would allow those people
to be defaulted we are open to
alternatives
that would
would
cause more certainty in the final
process because for
someone who's now the current process
allows for a default because the person
is given a hearing date in hand from a
law enforcement officer within that
habitual offender packet there are clear
warnings that if you fail to appear for
the hearing you will be certified
habitual offender and default in the
order then goes into effect and then
that order is mailed to someone who
defaults and it's
it's mailed based on the in-hand service
of the hearing notice so this would be
a change to
do first-class mail for the hearing
notice and the driver record to initiate
the process a couple of ideas that we
came up with a rather than allow for a
default
after the mail notice is either some
in-hand service of the default order or
another alternative rather than
defaulting the person who doesn't appear
at the hearing putting an additional
suspension or if their license is not
under suspension to put in place a
suspension of the license until they
appear to be served with the habitual
offender paperwork so we're open to
different ideas if the committee was
inclined to not go with this as written
we're in favor of it as written and
recommend ought to pass but we're very
open-minded in anything we can do
to
make this process better for citizens
and for the state that's what the intent
of this bill is i'm happy to take any
questions
thank you any questions for
representatives
mr casco how are you today i'm fine how
are you representative good to see you
um
you just made some a statement which i
picked up on that that might be a a way
to come to some common ground about what
could be done
i fully respect the idea that you're
trying to streamline the process and
make it happen better for
even for the offenders
i don't have any issue with that the
issue i have though is if
i don't know how many times you've
gotten your first class mail not
delivered properly
it happens
shouldn't there be some process here's
my question thank you for being patient
with me
shouldn't there be
you can do the streamline process to
begin with but then after that shouldn't
there be a
follow through where you go back to the
old system of hand delivered so that the
person
gets their day
to talk about whatever the issues might
be
yes representative i certainly think
that's that's fair
and
we mail out all other hearing notices
for every other hearing type and we are
very careful before defaulting someone
to make sure the hearing notice went to
the address of record on the system if
we get return mail we won't do a
suspension or if we've suspended and
then get return mail we'd vacate that
suspension because it's not fair where
we know someone didn't get the notice by
mail to then take action
so we would be very careful with with
this process before
simply defaulting by mail but we're very
willing to come to some common ground
less than well we're going to default as
habitual offender based just on the mail
notice some other process at the back
end because
the cases that are problematic are the
people that will who who fail to appear
at the hearing for people who appear at
the hearing the hearings examiner does
the hearing makes a finding right there
writes up a hearing order hands it to
the person reads them the hearing order
makes it very clear that you can't drive
to drive as a felony do you understand
you need to be decertified i mean we go
through a step-by-step process
when i certify someone i check off that
i have read every single
finding of fact on the habitual offender
hearing order
all our hearings are audio recorded so
that supports what we said to the person
at the time so if attorney halverson's
office gets a case for habitual offender
where someone appeared at the hearing
it's very clear
what notifications were done when they
go to prosecute so really the area to
find a solution that may be considered
unresolved is how do we best handle the
defaults if we're allowed to send out
the initial hearing notice by first
class mail
i have a follow-up sure thank you mr
chairman
um mr casco
this is a somewhat of a loaded question
and you can
not answer it if you choose to but
i'm struggling with whose responsibility
it would be to make that
change
is it
i i worry that it's not necessarily
legislative responsibility to make that
correction
or
could you bring language back to us that
would allow us to make that correction
i'm i'm
who's who should be doing that
correction is the question
in terms of an amendment to the current
bill representative yes i'm certainly
we're willing to
to bring back proposals if the committee
is inclined to do that at a work session
in fact i have a couple of different
that i kind of just drafted up yesterday
as
if if it came up that amendments were
the way that this the committee
preferred that we would submit those so
i'm i'm happy to email the committee the
the two that i kind of came up with
yesterday after i talked with attorney
halverson and then internally i spoke
with
lieutenant o'leary and mr keller from
the dmv we had a pretty lengthy meeting
trying to hash all this out and come up
with what our best proposal ultimately
would be
okay any other questions from the
committee
representative thompson
thank you
i appreciate
you testifying today
um
when there sent a letter of habitual
offender hearings
are they
already suspended at that point
i'd say most people are the the vast
majority are already suspended some
aren't it really depends on the type of
convictions it's possible for someone to
have 12 speeding tickets and qualify
although
i can tell you i i don't see those very
often but if you have 12 speeding
tickets and they're all plea by mails
and you qualify you pro you won't be
suspended yet you may be because demerit
points is another administrative
procedure
that 12 speeding to 12 speeding tickets
is a lot of demerit points so probably
you will have been suspended for points
before you get that 12th ticket but you
may have your license restored at that
time so you're coming in to get
suspended first for habitual offender
but it's more common that someone is
already under suspension for other
reasons by the time they qualify okay
follow
follow up um
what happens to someone if that's the
case if they haven't gotten the letter
yet they get stopped they're under
suspension are they going to go to jail
is there
what's the process habitual offender is
either a felony offense in most cases
it's a felony under the statute for
prosecuting habitual offenders if
someone has a dwi or a misdemeanor motor
vehicle offense that is part of the
convictions that certify them habitual
offender then that makes it a felony if
they don't have a dwi or a misdemeanor
motor vehicle conviction then driving in
violation of that order is a misdemeanor
so the 12 speeding tickets would be a
misdemeanor level habitual offender
prosecution if they're driving in
violation of that although now before
anyone has an habitual offender hearing
they're all served in hand with the
hearing notice
in the paperwork warns them if they
don't appear at the hearing they'll be
suspended in default
by not appearing one more if i may
um one more
how many a year roughly do you have how
many habitual offenders
it's around a thousand and i ran a few
of the numbers for the past several
years so in 2019 the total habitual
offender hearing so this is where we had
the procedure we commenced it was 1323
so we had 612 habitual offender hearings
out of those and then
498 were marked as unable to serve
213 did not appear at their hearing so
they were found habitual offender in
default so that was 800 out of the 1300
but there was this group of almost 500
who were unable to serve
so then who knows how many of those
since 2019 were tracked down and served
or went to the dmv to get their license
and were then served and then i'll skip
2020 because that was the covert year so
the numbers are way down but in 2021 it
was 1022
habitual offenders
585 had hearings and were certified 77
were defaults and would have been
certified and then 360
were marked as unable to serve so
between unable to serve and defaults
that is
those are are numbers that that we've we
try to deal with because really we want
to make those numbers small we want to
certify people at hearings
and
everyone knows what the result is and
they can resolve their case and get on
the path to getting their license
legally restored rather than
staying under suspension for years and
years and years thank you very much
you're welcome any other questions from
the committee
one question okay we're running late one
question okay i'll make it a brief
question thank you mr chair
thanks for taking the question so
the question i have is you mentioned 500
unable to serve in uh
would they be um
usually when you hear that number you
assume that they were unreachable the
address had changed and so forth so by
the provision in this if it becomes law
would that help you serve those people
would that still be problematic to reach
those people
no we think it would help because they
would get the notice by mail
as long as they've updated their address
they'll get it they'll know and they'll
come to the hearing so our hope would be
that the number of unable or not
appearing or defaults would be greatly
reduced by starting the process earlier
on closer in time than when they went to
court because i think another problem
with this
historically is that they go to court
for that that last conviction
it takes a year to serve them and get in
for our hearing
they thought they think they've resolved
everything and they may disregard even
after in
or if they haven't been served then
they'll kind of think well i'm all set
they they don't worry about habitual
offender even though in court in the
wavering acknowledgment of rights for
people who plead guilty to habitual
offender offenses there's a warning
about habitual offender in the plea
coliques in court the judges go through
habitual offender especially if someone
is known to qualify at the time of that
court hearing but people still a lot of
this is is fairly complicated into the
average person
even though they've had contact with the
system because they have several
offenses they don't quite understand
there are two separate procedures
okay thank you thank you any other
questions from the committee
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you representative kanye
i see no other pink cards is anybody out
in the audience who wish to speak on
this bill
i close house bill
1239 fn before we open the next one i'm
going to give the
clerk time to catch up
thank you
basically the same thing
just deals with suspensions and stuff
it's all about nail and notification
so i'm just gonna pass it over like i
did the last one
12 40.
okay
running a little late
i will call
house bill 1240 fn intercession
our first speaker is
representative walsh
good morning mr chair members of the
committee for the record tom walsh
represented from the town of hooksett
uh and once again i'm introducing 1240
uh is uh at the request of the
department of motor vehicles department
of safety
um
just for the sake of time this actually
deals with the same issue that the last
bill did this talks about notification
uh by first class mail as opposed to
certified a little different caveat in
this one a defendant on line eight shall
be presumed to have been served three
days after mailing of the notice
again there are people that spoke on the
last one
the last one was uh
um
habitual offenders this one deals
specifically with suspension and
revocation for default so with that i
would defer any questions to the
professionals in the room
for this
if the uh i just want to clarify if this
came directly from director bilecki also
as similar to the last bill yes it did
thank you
thank you representative
next up
britney
shoot
dmv department of safety
supports the bill
good morning members of the committee my
name is brittany xu i am the bureau
administrator of financial
responsibility this bill is at the
request of the department this is a
process
of being able to send notification of a
not served in hand citation
a not served in hand citation is one
that's written by law enforcement and
they indicated that the defendant
themselves did not receive this ticket
by them specifically in hand
the reason we are asking for this is
currently the process requires that we
send these notifications by a certified
mail
in addition to certified mail being
costly it also involves a time of
division members to prepare these
correspondences
get them over to our warehouse our
warehouse gets them out into the mail so
there's a lot of additional costs that
go along besides the certified mail
itself
so through this we're hoping to gain
efficiencies in our operation and we're
also looking to be more fiscally
responsible by decreasing the
expenditures to the department
currently
the postage rate is 7.33
per certification
that's the certification and the postage
u.s first class mail is currently 58
cents
last year or on an annual basis we spend
approximately sixty eight hundred
dollars in mailing alone
if we were to move to a first class mail
process it would save the department
approximately sixty two hundred dollars
for the month of december
we entered 52 not served enhanced
citations onto our database
of those 52 items 25 were returned
so for 52 items it cost us 381.16
for the returned items of that was 183
dollars and 25 cents
comparatively at an 80
savings
it would have initially cost us 30 and
16 cents and we would have gotten back
14.50 worth
just to give you an idea of the items
that are not served in hand the top
three items tend to be
non-inspections of vehicles
unregistered vehicles
and speeding
and in regards to
the presumed um
the three days after the mailing it
gives us a starting point
please know that after we mail these out
the ticket goes on to the system
after that 30-day mark the department
then sends a follow-up notice letting
them know they defaulted prior to a
suspension taken effect
with that i will be happy to take any
questions
any questions for this witness
go ahead reference crawford
thank you mr chairman my question is um
after 30 days
are do you mail out another notice
when they're in default or
first class or do you send it certified
mail thank you for your question the
default notification is also sent via
first class mail all of the
notifications from the department go out
first class mail
that notification lets them know that
they have an additional 30 days to pay
the citation itself
plus the administrative late fee prior
to going into suspension it is very
clear that the suspension time
and the date when it takes effect
any other questions representative
tulerski thank you mr chairman thank you
for taking my question i just want to
clarify because as we stated in the
previous bill the um
slowing of the u.s mail service in the
last couple years is concerning and the
three days
although in state mail concerns me a
little bit so i just want to clarify
that you're stating
that's just
nothing's going to happen on day four it
simply
sets the clock ticking for a 30 day
period thank you for your question you
are correct okay thank you
any other questions
thank you
next up
paul halverson
merrimack county attorney
would you turn on your microphone please
i would note that in a default in a
court environment the the judge will
issue a default from from the bench uh
that's one of the options that that the
judge has it's not a requirement but uh
it's it's an option uh again we come
down to the basic notice issue if
someone drives after a default such as
this and suspension uh occurs charging
them under
rsa26364 which is operating after
suspension re requires that they uh that
they knowingly commit deact
and
first class mail
draws into a question whether or not
they have proper notice
i'll refer to you back to my other
testimony any other bill
and if you don't mind
incorporating that by reference i'll end
it there and take any questions
thank you any questions for
the witness
representative terosha
thank you mr chair thank you sir for
taking the question
so
in this instance if this change becomes
law then somebody could be notified by
first class mail and within three days
of that notice assumed that they
received it so if they were traveling or
out of the away from their permanent
address they would
may not have gotten it would that be a
possibility i i guess one could one
could assume that yeah yeah and and then
you're also assuming that male is going
to get them within three three three
days
and you know by just by way of of of
background i think that the
post office has recently changed their
standards for delivery of mail i don't
think it's three days anymore i think it
might be five for first class mail i'm
not sure
i remember reading that in the news
somewhere
so
any further questions
seeing none thank you thanks sir
anyone else in the audience who wish to
testify on this bill
seeing none
i close
hb 1240 fn
i'm going to open up the hearing on the
next bill which is 1573.
representative bolden
europe
sorry about that
thank you mr chairman and members of the
transportation committee for allowing me
to introduce house bill 1573.
for the record i am representative
andrew bolden and i represent
manchester's ward 5. i'm going to keep
this really short i know we're short on
time
the current law 263 colon 12 roman
x
was passed in 2002 and as most of you
probably remember the world was a very
different place back then
i read through the hearing notes and the
impetus for the bill was a concern about
the privacy of the magnetic strip on the
back of licenses
lawmakers at the time were concerned
that businesses were recording and
storing information from this magnetic
strip and using it for marketing
purposes
now fast forward to 2022 we don't have
magnetic strips on our licenses anymore
companies really aren't interested in
gathering our information from our
driver's licenses to use for marketing
purposes
they use smartphone apps rewards
programs and credit card information for
all that now
additionally just in the past few years
i've had my driver's license requested
and copied multiple times
when i applied to refinance my house the
bank wanted me to take a picture of my
own license and email it to them
when i closed on the loan the closing
company took my license and photocopied
it
when i go to a new doctor's office or
dental office they take a photocopy of
my license
when i applied to become a driver for
uber and doordash
i had to send them a photocopy of my
license
that i had to take with my own cell
phone
if you get locked out of your facebook
account you have to send them a picture
of your license before they will unlock
it
times have changed and this new law
should be updated i'm sorry this law
should be updated to allow an individual
to take a photo of their own license or
someone else to take a photo of the
license holders of the license with the
license holders consent so that people
can go on with their lives in the modern
era and i'll take any questions
any questions for the witness
representative o'hara
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative don't we can't we
currently i'm just trying to understand
what the intent of this law is because
can't we currently give consent for our
license to be copied
uh thank you representative for the
question
um
we can give consent for our license to
be copied in a non-electronic manner so
somebody could
jot down the information on the front of
or that's contained on the front of the
license but they cannot take an
electronic copy so they couldn't take a
cell phone picture or use a scanner or
anything like that
any other questions from the committee
representative
fenton thank you for taking my question
so say you're purchasing a vehicle and
i've done this in the past when you're
going to the automobile dealership they
scan your license into the system are
you saying that's illegal at this
current law stance
thank you very much for the question
according to my reading of the statute
yes i believe it is
represented tolerski
thank you thank you representative
bolden um there's nothing here that
actually would
specify
how the person will um demonstrate
their um
consent
would it just be considered verbal since
it's not specified
thank you very much for the question
representative yeah i believe that a
simple verbal
consent would probably suffice
unless the committee you know would like
something else obviously they could
amend the bill
thank
you representative o'hara thank you mr
chairman just quickly offer her a
question wouldn't we not consider
consent being handing the license over
for the copy
i thank you for the question um i'm not
a i'm not a lawyer or a judge but i
would assume that a court would probably
consider that to be implied consent yes
anyone else from the committee
seeing none thank you representative
does anyone else wish to speak on this
bill
miss shoot come on up
good morning again brittany um we do not
have a position on this but i did want
to highlight that senate bill 311
311 also proposes changes to this um
statute so i just wanted to throw that
out there for consideration that is it
thank you thank you
anyone else
seeing none
oops
i have a question for the chair would um
mr oberdenko i believe is the director
of licensing be willing to take a
question
i think so
good morning mr chairman and members of
committee for the record my name is jeff
oberdank and i am with the division of
motor vehicles formerly with driver
licensing currently with registration
but i've got a
about 20 years worth of background in
driver licensing so i could certainly
take some questions but
just to touch on the testimony that was
given earlier
scanned and retained would mean scanning
the 2d barcode on the back of the
license and retaining that information
in a database
and some of the things we've had to
address in the past were companies that
were for instance sears was using that
information they would scan the license
if somebody was
returning tools or things and they were
keeping a database to find out if there
was any fraudulent activity
that was against the the prohibition in
2614 you could not do that
now photocopying the license when you're
test driving a car at the dealership
that's absolutely legal because it's not
keeping it electronically it's just a
photocopy
of the license and it's really just a
snapshot in time that you were there and
that you were purporting to be a
properly licensed driver at the time you
were test driving the vehicle
so
i i don't know if that answers the
question but just based on what i heard
from testimony scanning and retaining is
actually grabbing pulling the license
off the 2d barcode and keeping it in a
database
thank you um i remember a bill we had
last term perhaps
that touched on the same issue it had to
do with i believe a school system that
had a new security
concept where they would scan the
licenses of visitors to the school and
we had these discussions
i
believe that bill didn't go anywhere
can you just touch on a little bit
similar situations or say when you hand
it over to the doctor and they slide it
through a machine i'm assuming that's an
electronic capture am i correct in that
what they're doing is not allowed by the
law that is correct and i do remember
that bill from last year uh
representative and that was for the same
reason it was scanning and pulling that
information from that 2d barcode in the
back
which the information in that barcode is
everything listed on the front and that
was considered driver privacy
information that they were capturing and
keeping
you awesome i'm good thank you
anyone else
seeing none thank you could you fill out
a pink card well sure thank you
okay yeah
okay i close house bill 1573.
you
all right being 10 57 i'm going to open
up the public hearing on house bill
1463.
all right
i'll start over now that we have our
streaming going again um
being 1058 i'm going to open up the
public hearing on house bill 1463
relative to driver's licenses issued in
accordance with the real id act of 2005.
uh if you wish to sign in on the bill
for or against we have our blue sheets
out back please do if you care to speak
please fill out a pink card pass it
forward and we will get to you
and chair recognizes the prime sponsor
representative sykes
thank you chairman walsh and members of
the transportation committee for the
record my name is
representative george sykes i serve
city of lebanon grafton 13
and i'm here to speak in support of this
bill
before i get to the particulars of the
bill itself i just wanted to make
members of the committee aware of some
demographics or statistics that i think
are relevant to this bill
and that is that for the first time
in decades
new hampshire's
population increased
rather than decreased
and that's pretty significant because a
lot of states are losing population we
were fortunate that we according to the
2020 census the population in new
hampshire went up
behind that number
is another fact
that the largest single cohort
identifiable
are
legal immigrants coming into the into
the state these are people who come and
do
work for
various jobs from professionals to
agricultural work etc
and
i think
most would agree that having an
increasing population and the talent
that comes in from
this identifiable cohort is important
this bill will help support
that kind of inflow of population
at the present time
according to federal regulations and i'm
not going to get into the specific
details there might be someone else who
can do a better job of that
at the present time in new hampshire
if you are a legal immigrant
but not a citizen of new hampshire you
cannot get a real id
this bill would bring
new hampshire in alignment with the
federal regulations which allows
for a legal immigrant to get a real id
real id is important for a variety of
reasons not least of which is to
facilitate travel
and for the kinds of people that we were
for the people that are coming to the
state they may have opportunities to
travel for work
for family reasons and putting
roadblocks in their way is
counter to the best interests of the
state and
what i believe to be important thank you
i i will take it i'll take questions but
again i'm going to leave it up to some
other folks who can do a better job
maybe thank you representative any
questions from the committee
representative o'hara
thank you mr chairman thank you ranking
member i just had a quick question on
the last statement you just said when
you said they're
um legal immigrants but don't
live in new hampshire
no i didn't say that they are they are
illegal immigrants and they live here in
new hampshire thank you okay i've
misunderstood your last words
other questions from the committee
representative
thank you thank you representative sykes
can you just clarify again
to make sure that i heard it correctly
that in other states
around the nation
their
real id
can be issued to legal immigrants but in
new hampshire
as current statute is we cannot issue a
real id to legal immigrants
that is a that is how i understand to be
the current state of affairs okay i just
want to make sure thank you
any other questions
i have one just for clarification
um you mentioned legal citizens for work
and such i'm assuming that's green cards
or work visas
isn't there already
the way in law for them to get a
driver's license are you saying they
can't get a real id
so once you have a in new hampshire if
you are
an illegal immigrant in this state
you can get
a driver's license if you have a work
permit
what you can't but that is a
non-compliant
other than real id
license okay thank you
any other questions
seeing none thank you
next up chair recognizes martin toe
in support of the bill
check your microphone push the uh the
button on the right side
left side
good morning everyone
my name is marintel i am a member of the
granite state organizing project a
faith-based organization
in manchester um also part of the gsop
chapter
in manchester
i'm here today to testify
in support of hb 1460 um 63
relative to the driver's license
uh
i want to start off by saying you know
a driver license is a it's a beautiful
thing and uh and it's something that and
every person living within a community
should be able to enjoy uh specifically
in new hampshire
um
in order to get anywhere you you gotta
have a you know you need a vehicle and
having a real license that's not gonna
give you trouble is a good thing
i remember one day when my mother was in
pain and uh it seemed hopeless uh
i remember driving to the to the store
um over let's say
record speed
and turning back in record speed
simply to make sure that my mother
was okay
it was at also at the time where it was
the beginning stage of the pandemic
so i was praying to god that she didn't
have covet
what i'm trying to say is
regardless of the situation
people still need to make sure
that there's food on their table and
that involves
driving
whether
people still got to go to their work
and that involves driving people still
have to
you know um get to their jobs and in
order to do that you have to drive
uh or whether you're going to church on
a sunday
you gotta you gotta drive um or
whatever place of worship uh you go to
um the fed the federal rail id you know
legislation
it requires that all uh states and u.s
jurisdiction to issue a driver license
that are fully com compliant um by by
may 2023
so i'm asking this body as well to align
with uh
with with the law in congruent with the
federal law
um
yeah i just want to strongly urge you uh
to support hb um 16.
um i'm hb 1463
and uh and as a person of faith i i just
want to say it's the right thing to do
thank you
thank you for your testimony any
questions from the committee if you're
willing to take any
seeing none thank you very much
uh chair recognizes nadia gonzalez
in support of the bill
good morning my name is nadia gonzalez
and i'm here today
to request for this bill to be approved
i am here representing of many of all
that are out there
an
having the desire
like many to have
an id
in order to provide our family a better
to be
secure
in order to take our kids to school
more likely in these times of winter
it's not easy to walk them to school
with the snow
forest
that's why i'm here
apollyon
[Music]
uh this petition
thank you so much
thank you very much for your testimony
any questions
cnn thank you again thank you
uh next up
chair recognizes
i can't quite make out their last name
grace
kinderber
sorry about that uh also in support of
the bill
this doesn't get closer hello members of
the committee thank you for taking my
testimony my name is grace candecke i'm
the program coordinator with the
american friends service committee and i
am today i am submitting testimony on
behalf of the new hampshire immigrant
rights network which is a coalition of
new hampshire organizations and
individuals working with and within
immigrant communities to improve lives
and ensure just treatment my testimony
is written so i will be i will
paraphrase and submit written testimony
to the committee so the importance of
this bill is that it simply it's a
simple matter in that it brings new
hampshire into compliance with federal
law there are a number of categories
that
classes of applicants that would be
eligible for real id and in these
classes of applicants are not
being offered in the state these classes
of applicants are much broader than the
current eligibility standards that the
dmv offers and this law would bring our
state into compliance and open up these
categories which are already federally
passed
and make that available in to new
hampshire residents
it is mandatory as we know that the new
hampshire dnb allow all eligible
applicants to obtain real id
and this bill does simply does a simple
matter of bringing this our state into
compliance um so that's the technical
aspect of it and i think that's a very
important and it's the heart and spirit
of this bill um but also at the heart
and spirit of this bill is that part of
the
the those who would be eligible to be
able to drive what this bill would do
includes people like me includes people
in my community
as well as other immigrants in the state
for many for those who
none of you know me but i grew up in new
hampshire i've lived in the state since
i since 1989 when i was two years old
and i started to drive in 2018
and so when we are saying that this not
only does this bill bring us into
compliance it also allows an opportunity
for many new hampshire residents who
would be otherwise eligible to be able
to care for their families go to work do
the things that they need to do as we
all very well know living in the state
how difficult it is to get around and do
what we need to do without a car so i
urge the committee to please pass
hb1463
thank you
and i'm happy to take questions
thank you for your testimony any
questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much
did you have written is that good yes
okay if you could pass that forward it'd
be great sure who should i give it to
you
come on right down
next up chair recognizes actually hold
on one second
chair recognizes sarah sarah noy uh also
in support of the bill
representing gsop
good morning
my name is sarah jane kenoi i'm the
executive director of the granite state
organizing project and the convener of
the new hampshire immigrant solidarity
network i did not intend to testify
today although i do support this bill i
just wanted to note that earlier one of
the committee members asked a question
about
if a person has a work permit can they
not get a driver's license or a real id
and the problem is right at this moment
a person can be here 100 legally can be
qualified to work
and can be waiting for over a year
because of bureaucratic delays for that
work permit and so that is another
reason why this law is necessary is to
make sure that people who are qualified
to drive are able to get those driver's
licenses
so that's all i wanted to say about
uh this bill today i do hope you'll
support it thank you very much
no questions
thank you from
thank you for your testimony any
questions from the committee
seeing none thank you very much
our chair recognizes
bruno de britto
representing new hampshire brazilian
council in support of the bill
good morning mr chair good morning
members of the transportation committee
um
basically i'm just going to
be brief today some of my colleagues
already mentioned to you the importance
of
the passing of this legislation
at the very current moment new hampshire
does not comply with the federal federal
id act of 2005
passing this law will make sure that new
hampshire does comply when it becomes
effective in may 2023
we have
we have had issues
with individuals that are eligible to
receive
real id not being able to receive the
rio id
[Music]
driver's license at the dmv and it has
been you know dealt on a case-by-case
basis and this legislation will just
remove you know that that need and make
sure that new hampshire again is
compliant and provides a driver's
license to people who are otherwise
eligible
the current statute
reads that only u.s citizens are
eligible
and that's not what the real id says
so
i'm open to 20 questions
[Music]
thank you for your testimony any
questions from the committee
seeing none they let you off the hook
thank you
uh last pink card i have chair
recognizes
mr robertdank from the department of
motor vehicles
good morning mr chairman and members of
the committee for the record my name is
jeff obernank and i'm here to testify
today on behalf of the division of motor
vehicles about this bill
um and we are opposed to the bill
because of the language in the way that
it's written
but i've also heard a lot of testimony
about
how new hampshire is not in compliance
with the real id regulation and we are
in compliance that's the only way to get
approval
there is an approval process that goes
through homeland security that it was a
very strict approval process that we
went through
i personally wrote the submission and
received the
notice to proceed which is why we're
able to put the real id star on the
right-hand corner of the license the
only way to get that is to be in
compliance
so having said that i do want to look at
the language of the bill and draw your
attention specifically to
page two
line number seven
or excuse me line number nine that says
has a
pending
or approved application
for temporary protective status or a
pending application for asylum which is
on line eight and i also
hand it out to all of you a packet which
is the real id act and if you turn your
attention to page two
specifically probably about halfway down
the page
number two b
evidence of lawful status and i want to
draw your attention to the word shall a
state shall
require before issuing driver's license
or identification card to a person valid
documentary
evidence that the person and if you go
down through
you'll see specifically number four
which is in direct conflict
to the statute with to the to the
correction that's being written here in
the statute is has an approved
application for asylum
not a pending application and there's a
big difference
and the difference being is that when
you submit an application for anything
there is an approval process
no different than if you would apply for
credit or if you're purchasing a vehicle
there's an application
process and then there's an approval
process
having said that
had we issued real id compliant licenses
to people who are in the application
process
and would ultimately come back as being
denied for whatever reason we would be
in violation of the real id act
so having said that
i'll take any questions the committee
may have
thank you representative
o'hara thank you mr chairman thank you
director sorry
um so i just want to get this clear for
you if we do pass 1463 it would make us
now
not be in compliance with the real id
act the way it's written correct okay
thank you
representative thompson
the real id
license is a different license than what
most of us probably
have if we haven't renewed it is it
possible for people with a pending
application to get
a regular license and not a real id so
that they could drive on the roads
that's not possible and i'll draw your
attention to
263 39a and administrative rule 1002.06
where the process is clearly outlined
that says for any
type of driver license that there is an
approved process an approval process
that someone must go through
thank you representative
thank you mr chairman thank you taking
my question um
what is the difference
with number seven uh has a pending or
approved application for temporary
protected status in the united states
pending application would be for
somebody that's filed but that's not
gone through the approval process
so there's a and i've not had to go
through the process but you when you
when you apply for process there's
fingerprinting background check there
are those types of things that are done
before approval is is given
that's for any any type of status
further questions from the committee
representative
thank you thank you mr urban for taking
my question
so in the federal real id act
um it does not specify
united states citizenship
it it does it specifies
as one of the people that's eligible is
a
u.s citizen or
somebody who has one of the other
statuses that's listed in special
requirements section two
on page two of the real id act so it
gives you all of those other categories
as well
follow-up
so then is the
[Music]
only problem
the approved application for asylum as
it's
written because i know we've had this
discussion of the problems in the
waiting period right for asylum seekers
and that is
to your point representative that has
been the problem at some points i've
seen the weight go as long as eight or
nine months or even up to a year
sometimes for some of those applications
to go through
and in my 22 years it's changed with
every administration i've seen it as
quick as 30 days
in early years past and i've seen it as
as almost as far as a year out before
somebody gets approved
any other questions from the committee
cnn thank you very much
next up chair recognizes
the honorable neil kirk
um
thank you mr chairman for the record i'm
neil kirk i live in where
and
i have
a lot a number of questions about this
bill i'm not sure whether i support it
or oppose it
but this bill is complicated
and it expands the number of people who
will be eligible to get either real id
or non-real id licenses in new hampshire
and that's a very important policy
question for this committee
i would ask that you get
very significant legal and technical
advice from dmv and perhaps from the
department of justice
as to exactly whether we are in
compliance or not in compliance with the
real id act currently
and whether
what this bill does specifically on page
two
um
starting at line six number five and
going through
line 14
um
has five different categories
that may or may not be compliant with
real id and may or may not expand the
number of people who are eligible for
driver's licenses under this bill who
are not currently
the dmv gentleman mentioned number six
and number seven
on lines 8 and 9
with the word pending
explaining that person with a pending
application would be eligible for a
license in new hampshire real id license
in new hampshire
and that's contrary to the federal
regulations i'd also
like to point out to you on line 11 the
word is or
so one through nine in this category
all you have to do to be eligible is to
meet one of those not all nine but just
any one of them
the other point i'd like to bring to the
committee's attention is section c
starting on line 15
which says basically
that if a person
presents evidence of
items
five through nine in the prior paragraph
that i just mentioned
the individual can get a temporary
non-id driver's license
and c describes what has to be done
for this to happen and how long that
license is good for
so where this bill to pass
a person in the united states
who's i think physically in the united
states files an application for asylum
or files an application
uh for um
protected status
or has a valid non-immigrant or
immigrant id
or has approved deferred action status i
don't know what that means
or has an i 797 form showing pending
application that person will not be
eligible for real id or maybe eligible
for real id
but also would be eligible as he is not
now as i understand it for a new
hampshire driver's license non-real id
license
my concern only is that when this
committee makes its decision it be well
informed
and that you fully
understand which groups of people who
now cannot get either a real id or a new
hampshire driver's license you are
allowing to get under this bill
i don't understand this well enough to
be able to
um to give you an opinion but i do know
this is complicated enough that you
really need to get some expert advice on
this before you go forward with the bill
or all of us will be surprised by what
we've done
thank you very much mr chairman i'd be
pleased to answer any questions if there
are any from the committee thank you for
your testimony are there any questions
from the committee
cnn thank you very much thank you
that's the last person i have signed up
to speak um i'll give it a last call is
there anybody wishes uh that wishes to
speak to
host bill
seeing none i'm going to close the
public hearing thank you
all right
ladies and gentlemen um as noticed in
the calendar
we we can do executive sessions on some
legislation as time permits through the
course of the day
uh we're going to use up some of our our
down time here before lunch to exact a
few of our outstanding bills
um
i'm going to open the executive session
on house bill 1024.
let me get the title
relative to local speed limits in
businesses business or urban resident
districts
and the chair recognizes representative
ankerberg for a motion
thank you mr chairman i move itl on
house bill 1024. okay
second by representative gagne
you care to speak to your motion
uh yes thank you mr chairman i think the
the fear here is creating a patchwork of
varying speed limits across the state
that
drivers may not be familiar with
it was also brought up in the hearing
that there are seasonal waivers
to allow certain areas
to vary their speed limit
when needed in high traffic areas
and also bill lambert
from dmv was
opposed
and we value his testimony greatly
thank you sir um anybody else wish to
speak
to this bill
seeing none
i'll ask the clerk to call the roll when
she's ready the motion on the floor is
an itl on house bill 1024.
representative cagney yes
represented the clerk votes yes
representative hill yes representative
thompson yes representative ankerberg
yes representative gorski yes
representative o'hare yes
uh representative torreson yes
representative sykes yes
representative uh horrigan
yes
representative fenton yes
representative rambo yes representative
rich yes representative talaski yes
representative fox yes representative
schultz
yes representative veo
yes and chairman walsh yes
it should be 18. i've got 18. 18 18 0.
okay the motion of it
motion of itl um on tells bill 1024 has
been adopted 18-0
consent's been moved there's a second
seconded any opposition to consent
seeing none i'll close the public
hearing
i'm in the executive session on house
bill 10 24.
we have time for a couple of more if you
give us a moment to reset
what's next
welcome back
i'm
going to open up the executive session
on house bill 1138
accepting the display of front license
plate on certain vehicles
um is there a motion
there
yep
representalerski thank you i'd like to
make a motion of itl on house bill 1138.
representative tolerski moves itl is
there a second
second by representative fenton
do you care to speak your motion sure
as we all know this bill has come
through this committee
a number of times
and i keep going back to
law enforcement and supporting our law
enforcement
i know there are other states that don't
have
the front plate requirement
however when i hear from
the police association the chiefs of
police hollis farmington
the state police
as well as
the dmv
and the concerns about toll collection
which we didn't exactly get into
specifics of the public hearing
but the most recent information that
i've heard um is that there's about 40
of
unpaid tolls
due to lack of reading the front plates
i would suggest that we find this bill
inexpedient to legislate
for those reasons
but i also have an issue with the
verbiage of collectibility
um historic character and the ambiguity
of the bill on how that's supposed to be
determined thank you
thank you anybody else
representative o'hara
thank you mr chairman and yeah i'm a
huge supporter of
getting rid of the front license plate
but hearing that testimony from the
police did kind of change my mind on
that for now
thank you sir anybody else
seeing none
i'll ask the clerk
representative erosion
thank you mr chair um
i intend to vote
against the prevailing motion
we have many
drivers
in vehicles that come to the state of
new hampshire from other states that
don't require
a front license plate and it's a
non-event
think the the some of the uh
items that were mentioned are overblown
easy pass can have cameras that
can pick up the rear plate
as many of you know we have scanning
devices that law enforcement use to get
the plate number
further the uh
during night time operation of the
vehicle that front plate's not lit
so
if this was such an important
thing to have
i would think by now somebody would have
passed or
presented legislation to
to light up the front plate
so it's a good
half of the time particular time of the
year you you can't even see it
so i think there's some good reasons to
allow it and um
i think
we've we've heard some of these items
before for the reason to be against it
but i i don't think i think if we're
really worried about it we would we
would have a policy that would require
other states when they
you know other drivers from out of state
when they come here to new hampshire to
display a plate so um it can't be that
big of a problem thanks
thank you anybody else
representative horrigan
i'll just point out first this must be
sub day great what
yes i'm subbing here so i just want to
point out though an issue that comes up
all the time in um
in
in in all committees is this does
require a
new fee and that's why it's an early
bill but also requires hiring a due
state employee so i know there's
many members of the house who are um
very skeptical about any new fee and
also hiring any new state employees and
this bill requires both some
i mean
i plan to vote for the ital on its
merits but that's another just
consideration i thought i'd bring up
thank you anybody else
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the role when she's ready the motion on
the floor is itl on house bill 1138
representative gagne
yes
represent clerk votes yes representative
hill no
representative thompson
yes
representative ankerberg
representative gorski yes
representative o'hare
yes
representative sykes
oh i'm sorry i'll take the
representative torreson sorry no
representative sykes yes
representative horrigan
uh yes on the ito yes okay
representative fenton yes
representative rambo
yes representative rich yes
representative toloroski yes
representative fox yes representative
schultz yes representative vega
yes
and chairman walsh
no okay
fifteen to three
okay so the motion of itl on house by
1138 is adopted 15-3
looks like this will be going to the
regular calendar
that closes the executive session on
on that bill
we have one more we can do before we
break for lunch we had an issue with
house bill 1060. i'll explain in a
minute we'll take a moment just to get
reset thank you nobody's doing a
minority or a
majority of report or anything like that
what are we doing now
okay i'm going to open up the executive
session
once again on house bill 1060. i have
checked with the clerk
we are still in possession of it it has
not been
submitted to to their office so
the chair recognizes representative
talersky for a motion
thank you mr chair i'd like to make a
motion of reconsideration on house bill
1060 fn authorizing the new hampshire
environmental educators to issue decal
plates
any second to the motion of
reconsideration representative hill
wish to speak to emotion yes please um
for those of you who were here at the
hearing last week the prime sponsor did
not show up because it was a decal bill
um we did the necessary check thing
check the 501c3 status
but something has come to light so if we
can reconsider this bill which has the
support of the sponsor we can then go on
with a next motion
fair enough anybody else
seeing none um this is for
reconsideration um
if you're favoring reconsidering it's a
yes i will be voting yes when the clerk
is ready she can call the role please
uh vice chairman cagney yes
clerk votes yes representative hill yes
representative thompson yes
representative ankerberg yes
representative gorski yes representative
o'hare yes representative torreson yes
representative sykes
yes representative horrigan
yes representative fenton yes
representative rambo
yes representative rich yes
representative tollerski yes
representative fox yes representative
schultz yes representative vahu yes and
chairman walsh yes
18-0
i don't know
18-0 yeah
okay
so uh the motion to reconsider has been
adopted 18-0
so now we're back we resort back to the
current motion about to pass
back
on the floor
um
anybody cared to speak to the motion of
ought to pass
thank you
so
we can't just make a separate we're
reconsidering
no what we're going to have to do
the motion to reconsider was one action
and so now
by rules we have to
take up the state the motion on the
floor which is ought to pass yeah turn
it down
if that's our wishes yeah and then make
another motion to to round it off just
trying to be clear about it thank you
yes it is going to be three votes
well i
unless we say ought to pass again but i
don't know
so did you care to speak to this motion
i would thank you thank you thank you
very much um just to explain what
happened
with this uh bill um
i reached out to the prime sponsor to
inquire as to why she wasn't here to
present
it was a scheduling mix-up but that
doesn't matter what she did point out
was that the organization that's named
in this bill
actually
um reached out to her
the week prior and said that they would
like to politely decline the offer of
being part of the multi-use decal
bill plate program
um i question that
the uh prime sponsor then uh looked a
little further into it and i think that
what she found is probably useful
information for all of us as we get
these bills in the future
the organization looked at the list of
non-profits that are approved in statute
one of them is the harris science center
which i believe we
passed my first term maybe 2019
and they reached out and said how do you
like the program
and the harris science center said it's
the biggest mistake we've ever made as
an organization
they
went through the process filled out the
paperwork said it was quite onerous
they spent the money to produce the
decals that fit the specifications of
the program
then they
tried to sell them
in the course of three years they have
sold 12 decals
the organization is in the red over a
thousand dollars for this program
some of the things that they brought up
was
people are very attached to their plates
their moose plates their state park
plates their vanity plates they don't
want to have to
trade them in
then go get the new decal plate and then
buy the sticker
so for all these oh they all she also
said that for these science
environmental programs they are directly
in conflict with everyone who loves the
moose plates and the state park plates
so
at the request of the prime sponsor
i would ask that you vote down
the otp motion that's still on the floor
and so that another motion can be made
but i also think as a committee we need
to keep this information in mind as
these organizations come to us
i truly wonder if some sponsors
understand what's involved with the
program
that money is needed
to be put up front that there's a lot of
paperwork involved
and i think for some organizations it's
a great program the
university system of new hampshire has
the the means the numbers the the
bandwidth to handle it um i believe the
girl scouts that we heard last week does
also
but for some smaller organizations this
is definitely not a program for them so
with that i would be voting against the
otp that's on the floor and encourage
you all to do the same
what's that
the otp is automatic on the floor
because once we've reconsidered we go to
the original motion
so right now it's otp
anybody else from the committee
seeing none uh that might be well good
advice for some of the smaller
organizations in the future um there was
valuable information so the motion on
the floor is ought to pass once again on
house bill 1060.
i'll ask the clerk to call the roll once
soon as she's ready
vice chairman gagne
no
clerk votes no representative hill no
representative thompson no
representative ankerberg no
representative gorski no representative
o'hare no representative torreson no
representative sykes no
representative horrigan
representative fenton no representative
rambo no
representative rich no representative
talaski no representative fox no
representative schultz no representative
vayu no chairman walsh no
18 to zero okay so the motion not to
pass uh fails 18-0
is there another motion
representative tolerski i make a motion
of ito on house bill 1160 and i don't
need to speak to that yeah okay uh
motion is uh in expedient to legislate
is there a second
representative by representative phil
seconds
any discussion
seeing i'll ask the clerk to call the
roll and she's ready
the motion is itl on
hill house bill 1060.
yes
clerk votes yes
representative hill yes representative
thompson yes representative ankerberg
yes representative gorski yeah
representative o'hare yes representative
torreson yes representative sykes
yes representative horrigan yes
representative fenton
representative rambo yes representative
it rich
yes representative talarsky yes
representative fox yes representative
schultz yes representative yes
chairman walsh
yes okay 18 to 0.
okay the motion of ito
is adopted 18-0 in house bill 1060.
um
is there another motion
consent's been moved can i get a second
seconded by o'hara any objections
seeing non-consent that is final notes
on this to all the kids from hollis we
did we did our best
this isn't our fault
and and remember never give up the fight
so
i'll close the executive session on
house bill 1060.
and that'll get us to lunch
and then we've got a few more
public hearings this afternoon and an
exec session at 3.
okay did everybody have a good lunch
all right i'd like to open up
the transportation house session on
house bill
1666 fn
first up would be the prime sponsor
representative sykes
chairman gagne and members of the
transportation committee thank you for
allowing me to introduce
this bill house bill 1666.
one of the things that i would like to
bring to the attention of the committee
is that
it is
in my mind and i think in yours too
a primary purpose of the legislature is
to fix problems for the residents of
this state where problems exist if
they're within
our purview and they can be fixed
so this bill is trying to look at
a problem of
public safety that's what i want to
emphasize again and again and again
this bill is about public safety
whether we
like it or not
there are people who drive in this state
who do not who are do not have a
driver's license
and in some instances they are
undocumented persons as well
the public safety angle of this is if
they're going to drive
it's better from a public safety point
of view for
us to know
who they are
where they live
and if they're competent drivers
this bill would require
anybody who's qualifies otherwise
to take the written exam
and the practical exam before any
license would be issued because driving
is a privilege and we recognize that
the other part of this that i would like
to
point out is
one of the things that
many police departments and public
safety agencies are trying to accomplish
in this state
is to have a more active presence in
what they
typically call
community policing
to do that you have to connect with the
community
and if you have a segment of people who
live in your community who are afraid
for whatever reason
to interact with the police that's not
healthy or helpful
so
um
for those reasons and many more
i've
put this bill in the other thing i would
point out to you as well is that
in talking to various public safety
organizations
they have begun to recognize that this
is
an important constituency that they want
to connect with because they can tell
them
about things that are happening in their
community
the other thing is there's probably
the numbers are very i can't provide the
documentation but it's thought to be at
least fifteen thousand undocumented
people in this state
finally
we are not
creating new ground here
and i say that because there are the
last time i checked
and please don't hold me to this exact
number but i believe there are
at least 15 states that have programs
like this
where they're trying to get everybody
licensed
two of the nearest ones are vermont and
while new york is not contiguous with us
new york also
they allow undocumented persons to go
through a process
that proves that they are safe community
drivers
with this kind of documentation some
other pieces can fall into place
they can for instance get car insurance
that's
really helpful for many many people so i
would urge you to have an open mind
about
what problem it is that we're trying to
fix and that problem is that we have a a
segment of population driving in the
state who have not proven that they are
safe
responsible drivers and we would like to
bring them in the fold so that that can
be shown
and without take any questions if i can
i'll answer any questions any questions
from the committee
seeing none thank you
next up is grace kendecki i think i
pronounced that correctly i hope
can decay
okay
here we go okay thank you
so hello members of the committee uh
thank you again for taking my testimony
my name is grace candecke i'm the
program coordinator for the american
friends service committee and so i come
here with a testimony that i will also
submit to the committee and i will pray
our phrase from the immigrant rights
network a group of passionate activists
organ and organizations that we can that
afsc convenes
we strongly urge the committee to pass
hb 1666 if passed this bill would allow
members of our community who are
undocumented to be able to drive without
a license
and to drive with a license i apologize
the bill has the support of many law
enforcement leaders as well as members
of the immigrant communities as well as
advocacy and faith groups and it is time
for our state to join the growing number
of jurisdictions across the country that
have concluded that licensing
undocumented drivers would be beneficial
to the state and to all of the residents
these benefits include removal of an
unnecessary burden on law enforcement
and our criminal legal system because
operating without a license in new
hampshire is currently a criminal
offense and oftentimes for undocumented
members of our community it is the one
criminal offense that they are liable
for
it is unnecessary to burden law
enforcement and the entire criminal
legal system by criminalizing conduct
that could be legalized by expanding
expanding licensing eligibility
another benefit includes increased
public safety
because undocumented in new hampshire
residents are not currently eligible for
driver's licenses there is no systematic
operator or respect of this group of
people
permitting this group this population to
be able to drive
would benefit not only them but their
families as well as the state it would
actively
it would positively identify the driver
it would more effectively regulate motor
vehicle operators it would be a safer to
operate vehicles on our roads and it
would as um
representative sykes said it would
increase insured drivers on our roadways
so
being an undocumented immigrant is not a
criminal offense although it is a
federal misdemeanor to enter the united
states without permission the majority
of people unlawfully present here are
those who entered with the visa and
remained after the visas expired they
have built their families they have many
of them are working are supporting their
families and their communities and
enabling them to be able to drive
especially in the state of new hampshire
where a car is so necessary is
critically important
undocumented immigrants are part of this
community they contribute to our way of
life to our economy to our schools in
our workplaces
by decreasing the fear between our
undocumented populations as well as with
our law enforcement it creates a
community that is much more able to
effectively address the larger issues
that are needed to be addressed in order
for people to feel that they can move
safely and work safely in the state
so i urge you all to please to pass this
bill because of the benefits that it
would have for our community
for our popular undocumented immigrants
in the state as well as for unburdening
the criminal legal system thank you
i'm happy to take questions
any questions
for the witness
yeah representative thompson
good afternoon miami thank you for
testifying
um i think what you're asking us to do
is to legalize
someone who's already illegal to begin
with
and i i'm sorry but i can't i don't
grasp the
is that your question
i'm not sure how to phrase the question
but yeah it is a question if you're here
illegally for us to legalize a driver's
license for you
gives
i would think the state some sort of
liability
ask a question
is that or isn't that not
true is that working now all right
so to answer your question no that is
not true what the this bill would allow
is it would it would systematize being
able to give people driver's licenses so
it would give people the ability to
drive within the state within the rules
and the regulations of the state it does
not offer legal status it does not offer
anything other than the ability the
proven ability to drive within the laws
and regulations of the state
no no follow up just let it go
any other questions
oh i'm sorry
go ahead thank you mr chair
representative schultz nice to meet you
um
hasn't
haven't other states
passed laws similar to this
yes they have i apologize i don't have
the exact states that but i do know that
my colleagues who will also be
testifying can give the exact number and
names of those states but yes other
states in the country have passed
similar laws for to their benefit
any other questions
thank you ma'am could you bring
that copy i do for our clerk it makes it
a lot easier for her absolutely thank
you thank you
next up would be sarah knox i believe or
noy
from the gsop
that's kanoi
so my apologies sure
good afternoon my name is sarah jane
canoy i am here today representing the
granite state organizing project as i am
the executive director
thank you for the opportunity to provide
testimony on house bill 1666
the granite state organizing project is
a faith-based organization working with
religious communities of all types all
across new hampshire
our work is guided by our shared faith
and democratic values
since
2017 we have been convening diverse
faith leaders congregations and
communities to support new hampshire
immigrant families and this group
includes people from every county faith
communities and churches from every
county in new hampshire
we all urge you to support house bill
passage of house bill 1666 will increase
public safety all across new hampshire
communities
allowing people to obtain driver's
licenses while they are awaiting the
outcome of legal filings court cases or
adjustment of immigration status
will greatly decrease the fear of law
enforcement in immigrant communities
many encounters with new hampshire law
enforcement officers occur within the
context of motor vehicle activities
therefore many immigrants including
those legally present fear and avoid
contact with law enforcement
this may lead to unreported crimes
failure to appear as a witness or a
defendant in court and other
consequences that affect a community's
quality of life
i personally have a friend in manchester
named susan who was brought here as a
child by her parents grew up here
married a legal resident here had
children and was driving her child to
her dance lesson in goffstown one night
when an illegal left turn resulted in a
police stop
what should have been simply a ticket or
a warning became a nightmare for this
family as susan was taken to immigrant
detention
for two weeks leaving her family
alone her children traumatized and those
children still today are terrified when
they see a police officer
she's back at home now but the trauma
lingers
the wait times for processing most
immigration applications have increased
and people who have applied for lawful
status
may have to wait months and sometimes
years depending on the type of petition
they have filed for adjudication of
their application
the ability to drive lawfully during
this waiting period would decrease
stress and fear for families with loved
ones awaiting approval of a lawful
status
additionally studies show that licensed
drivers are safer drivers and are more
likely to purchase auto insurance
this will make our streets and highways
safer for everyone
in closing if you are worried that
possession of a driver's license would
lead to ineligible people voting or
accessing state services
please be aware
that a driver's license does not confer
the right to vote or establish
eligibility for any state or federal
benefit
eligibility to register to vote in new
hampshire is based on u.s citizenship
age and domicile
each state and federal benefits program
is highly regulated and sets out
eligibility standards in their
regulations and none of these standards
are tied to the possession of a driver's
license
thank you for your consideration i urge
you to support house bill 1666
i'm happy to take any questions and i do
have a copy for the clerk
thank you for both any questions for
this committee from this representative
telersky thank you mr chairman thank you
for taking my question
um
last year when we heard a similar bill
i recall uh my own police chief
who's since retired michael carrigan
from nashua testified in support and he
brought up the importance of
community relations and and
community policing excuse me
and what struck me and you touched on it
but i'm wondering if you can expand on a
little bit more is that many crimes go
unreported including sexual assaults
um
you know robberies attacks anything like
that can you just expand on on how this
one uh document can help improve the
trust
of people with the system
thank you for your question and yes
we've worked extensively with manchester
and nashua police departments and and
many police officers do support
this idea
you know it can be standard procedure
for an officer to ask for id when
responding to a call
and even if i'm a citizen
if my husband is not whether he's an
asylum seeker whether he's applied for
some kind of status but if he doesn't
have a driver's license i'm going to be
afraid to call the police into my home
because the police will ask for
identification
and then the police may call
customs and immigration enforcement and
it may result in time in jail so
yeah it just it's clear
representation
thank you mr chair thank you man for
taking the question you indicated in
your testimony that um
drivers are more likely to purchase car
insurance uh when they have a driver's
license
do you have a
could you supply the committee with a
copy of a report that uh that shows that
i can find it yes i can thank you thank
you thank you for your question
any other questions um
i keep forgetting your name i'm sorry
okay i'm that's i'm representative
schultz but i'm also friendly so it's
okay
um
did you know that to get car insurance
you typically need a driver's license
and to submit the copies
for your driver's license yes you can't
get car insurance for the most part
unless you have a driver's license so
that's why i believe that we would all
be safer if we're not if we have uh
reduce our chance of getting um
interactions with uninsured drivers yes
thank you for your question
anyone else from the committee
seeing none thank you and you can just
come right up with that hand it to us
just watch your step
thank you
no there's more than one car here take
that
and pass that down if you like you like
it there
next up is
david gunty is that correct
representing himself in support
hi everybody thanks for this opportunity
to be here my name is david conscious
and i want to testify by myself like a
really real immigrant in the united
states
uh when i arrived here like uh nearly 30
years ago
and i came to peabody mass it's a north
shore
and i heard that about a connecticut
state and that time almost 30 years ago
then they gave opportunity to immigrants
to have a student show cell secured and
that time i got my with that i was able
to get on my driving license in
massachusetts because i was able to fill
the application and soon then i got my
driving license i got a job i can have a
full-time job i save my money i open up
in my account bank and i do my credit in
two years i have a 820 point in my
credit report and i was able to borrow
my first home
and besides that i bought my first home
and i gonna be closed from today today i
have three homes in new hampshire and
i'm all ready to buy another one and i
have a true business by myself and two
buildings with my wife
and also i have a degree i have a on a
bachelor
and theology
i have a master and counseling i have a
doctor and psychologist and i have a phd
in neuroscience
behavioral and also my
next school i like to have a law school
to help the immigrants here about the
immigrants so that's a happen
when the people have opportunity to have
a driving license here if you i don't
have that opportunity so it's like every
immigrant lives here all money they can
meet at they're going to send out of the
country they're going to invest in
another country if the money is going to
get out here because the immigrants is
still here but when they have
opportunity here to have a son like a
driver license they're going to get a
different mind they're gonna be saved in
this country if they're gonna invest
here for hard job but then they do it so
that's it's myself example then i did
during 30 years here so that's
everything then i have to talk about it
thank you very much for the opportunity
thank you for your testimony any
questions for this witness
seeing none thank you welcome
i'm going to take a stab at this one
frank nack
how close was i
not close enough though
mr chairman members of the committee my
name is frank knack i'm the policy
director with the aclu of new hampshire
i have my colleague jill bisonette i
believe emailed the committee copies of
his testimony on this bill and i have
hard copies with the chair's permission
to hand out
after after my testimony
most of our points have already been
covered so i don't want to repeat what's
already been said um you know i think in
general as you've heard from a public
safety standpoint both from a roadside
from a road safety perspective and also
from a strengthening community police
trust
this is a good idea and a really
positive ability i think there was a
question around the number of states
that have implemented this thus far and
through our research we found 16 states
plus the district of columbia
do not
limit the ability to get a driver's
license based off of immigration status
and then again just from a you know
basic human decency recognition of the
practicalities of living in a rural
state like new hampshire
it driver's license is necessary to
survive in our state you know as you all
know to get to school to get to work to
get to the doctor's office
you need to get on the roads and so
ensuring that all folks in our state
have the ability and access to do that
and to do so lawfully we think is
important and so this is a really
positive bill and we hope the committee
will will support it so thank you
thank you any questions for the
witness
seeing none you can hand that right to
that lady here and make sure the clerk
gets a copy
guys
next up would be
sadier montero
yo hablo espanol solimite poco
good morning
go good afternoon sorry angela mercado
and i will be her interpreter so she
said good afternoon and thank you for
the opportunity that you have given me
my name
my name is saitier montero and i am from
nashua
bengal in favor de la comunidad
que no tiene lisencia para conducir
i come in favor of the community that
has no license to drive
a necessity
as we all know having a license is a
necessity in our daily lives
it is very important that we can all
have a license in order to drive without
fear
contact
i am going to give you a testimony that
i had to go through from
from our for my family members
i was with the mother that was driving
um
going to
the school to
drop off the children la policia por
sierta
in many occasions um the police would
stop near the school
homage
to
i leave this terror with this family
that um
the children were were horrified
terrified because the police had stopped
them and had asked for the license
[Music]
i witnessed how the mother was taken and
was arrested by the police and i saw the
children how they were
terrified
bengal
[Music]
in favor of this
petition right the um 1666 about the um
license
is
hopefully you can put your hand in your
heart and and in fact hopefully that
you can do something in this situation
with the latino community that doesn't
have
a license
gracias
thank you
thank you for your testimony do we have
any questions for the witness
seeing none thank you
next up is bruno de brito
all right mr chair i have a copy
of my testimony here
just give it to that late woman at the
end so
representative
schultz
tool off to your position you can just
call me state representative or
representative
yeah so i have also provided a copy to
all of you electronically i'm sorry yeah
saving some paper and some ink
okay good afternoon mr chair
good afternoon again members of the the
committee
my name is bruno de brito
and i am president of the new hampshire
brazilian council
and i am also an immigration attorney
but today i'm going to testify on my own
capacity here
first i would like to to start
by
clarifying that immigration law
is a civil matter and not a criminal
offense
the first immigration laws that really
started to
to to guide and shape the history of the
united states and start requiring
visas to enter into the united states
was established in 1924
so that was the immigration act of 1924.
uh but the law the requiring visas to to
come in uh really didn't start uh
getting forced until 1929 when the
border patrol was established which
today we call it customs and border
patrol which is a an agency under the
department of homeland security umbrella
with if we apply
um today's laws
to
uh when your ancestors
came to this country
your parents grandparents
great-grandparents
would be called
asylees which is someone that is seeking
asylum who is going to to another
country because they you know because of
fear of
prosecution uh for you know whatever
reasons
and
um
and unfortunately and unfortunately you
would actually be able to to become you
know like legalized after
thankfully to the 14th amendment once
you get borned into this country
so second
i would like to to address
some of the issues that have
been brought up over their years
in regards to
this legislation
and immigrants per se
one issue was that the state of new
hampshire doesn't have the power
to
to enact this legislation that is not
true we all know under the 10th
amendment that the powers that have not
been delegated to
uh to the federal government uh are
given to today states
and policing power which is the power to
provide licensing
is
given to the states and not the federal
government
immigrants are not criminals
as i have stated above
immigration is a civil matter and not a
criminal offense
immigration and customs enforcement only
detains individuals
simply to make sure that they will show
up at a hearing in the immigration court
nothing else
in addition uh there is a study
conducted and published in
called the marshall project
showing that there is no correlation
whatsoever
between
undocumented immigrants
growing in a particular area and crimes
also growing in the in the area
so the state showed that even though
there had been an increase of
undocumented
immigrants in the nashua metro area
which also includes manchester
uh the the crimes actually remained the
same and we're talking about property uh
you know crimes against property and
crimes against persons
so
[Music]
we um
so the threat is not really you know
like what we think it is
uh since to 2019
uh the fbi and the department of
homeland security
have created many
uh reports showing that the actual
threat to our national security our
country
is white supremacists not isis and not
immigrants white supremacists
another issue suspend for a minute
please yes
please avoid using those terms like
white supremacists and all that please
avoid using those just just stick to the
facts here
please so i am i am sticking to the uh
to the facts
so who's telling you that
white supremacy
i'm sorry where did you get the white
supremacy so mr chair please refer to
tab a
tab 8 tab a letter a as an apple
so mr chair i am being respectful
uh i just want to point it out apologize
if i'm if i have offended
any members of the the committee i'm
only stating facts
may i proceed mr chairman sure
thank you
so continuing
uh immigrants are not allowed to to vote
in new hampshire
in order to to be eligible to vote and i
as my colleague sarah jane have stated
the person has to to prove their age
their citizenship
they must be a u.s citizen
and show residency
in the state otherwise they're not
eligible to vote
once they
they can prove that they can register
with
the clerk's office in their town or city
uh and then their names are get entered
into
a roster
that's when uh someone
that we go to to the polls and then we
cast our votes but we can only do that
if our names are in the tally you can
show your driver's license
if you are not u.s citizen as a matter
of fact we have many permanent residents
in the state green card holders that do
have a driver's license person who
persons who are not green card holders
that do have a driver's license and we
haven't had a history
of any of these individuals voting in
the state
um as a matter of fact
it can be
um it can be a very serious um
crime not crime but offense and actually
permanently bar someone from getting
any immigration benefit later on if they
vote when they're not allowed as a
matter of fact i have provided um a
guide of
the laws mr chair
that shows the types of
crimes and one of them
is voting when you're not authorized
so the other issue that has constantly
been brought up is that immigrants are
important
to the state and they cost a lot of
money to to the state and this country
uh that is untrue
uh in new hampshire we have
approximately 15 000 undocumented
immigrants
these immigrants are not eligible to
apply for any government assistance such
as wic food stamps etc
in addition these immigrants they have
paid a total of 77.1
million dollars in federal and state
taxes
with a household income
of
595.4 million dollars
into
in 2019
i have also provided um
uh on tab d uh the the study
in general uh in the state we have uh 87
immigrants
uh who have paid 1.1 billion dollars in
taxes
with a 3 billion dollar expanding power
amongst these immigrants
do you know which country is the most
populous
uh between undocumented and undocumented
immigrants in the state
you are correct canadians i'm sure some
of you might have thought mexicans but
it's actually canadians
so
and the other issue is that immigrants
don't pay taxes as i have just mentioned
they do pay taxes
um
so they they pay taxes using what it's
called an itin number uh which is a
number given by the irs
uh another way that they they pay their
taxes that they establish their own
companies and they actually end up
hiring us citizens and people who have
green cards to to work for them helping
our economy
so moreover
there are currently 17 states in the
district of columbia that have passed a
similar legislation
so i also provided the
the documentation on tab f
last but not least these states have
shown that there are many benefits by
providing a legislation such as this
maryland
have reports you know numerous reports
uh showing that
giving a driver's license increases
public safe safety as representative
terlaski have mentioned
we have um we have conversations with
many chiefs of police and that's one of
their concern if they stop someone uh
they prefer you know that that person
has some sort of identity that they're
able to identify who they're talking to
so minnesota have shown that there has
been an increase on in earnings and it
helps to to boost the economy because it
gives more mobility to its residents
going uh from one side to the other
within the state
new jersey also the same thing show that
the tri-state area with new york and so
forth show that there is a higher
mobility and it helps the state's
economy north carolina
also
also attests to its public safety and
boost of
therefore i urge you to do the the right
thing as a human being
as your ancestors once have been in the
same place as these individuals have
been
today to vote ea to allow thousands of
families to stay together and not have
the constant fear of being deported
every time they get into a car
thank you
thank you for your testimony any
questions for the witness
seeing none thank you thank you
mr chairpoint of personal privilege
representative schultz yes sir thank you
mr chair i just want to be clear
i'm sure your concern over white
supremacy was in no way to defend white
supremacy but to say that white
supremacists
are not welcome here
absolutely which is why
i don't like the n word either i think
that's bad
thank you
next up is eva castillo
she
she's in the meeting okay i'll hold off
and see if she comes back
sandra regina pratt
good afternoon everybody thank you for
the opportunity also to be here
i am sandra pratt i work for i live in
nashville new hampshire 254 lake street
i work for gateways community services i
am a bilingual service coordinator there
and i am also a secretary of our new
hampshire brazilian council so
um
as a council we we
provide all the support that our
community need
and i see i live united states i i'm i'm
also from another country i don't
consider myself like immigrant or
alien or this or that i am a
person
and i live in this country for more than
20 years and i see the need the urge to
have this driver's license for everyone
that can pay the fee
that is able to drive
that can
pass on a test on a written test
in the drivers you know the practical
test
to have a driver's license to me it's
like a
a simple thing
any adult any you know you have the age
you have all the ability you have the
financial
capacity
just take the test and drive safely to
me as simple as that
so
many other states already have
this law passed i think it's 17 or 18
other states i'm not
i'm sure
so
i hope that new hampshire will be the
next one
that will take this um in consideration
that will approve this
law and
why i wasn't ready for this
today and i think that's
i think that's what i wanna
i wanted to say today that i
live here for a long time that i see the
need that i think the people we have we
have plenty examples we many of us
already gave some examples to you to all
of you
the importance to drive safely
um
not to be caught by the police for you
know for the light to be broken and then
have other issues
so um
[Music]
because i i am a
um from another
country i would say
we all that are from other countries
suffer i already say this here um some
micro aggression which is like a little
mosquito bite you know oh your english
is not good enough oh where are you from
oh you don't have driving license oh
what's wrong with you those kind of you
know everyday
little mosquito bite little
microaggression
so the driver's license is a big one not
just for adults but for children
for many many people and i would like
that
we would call like
people people not
alien or immigrants or this or that
we're all human beings we're all people
so that would be
something nice to consider too and i'm
here just to say that i'm on favor that
i think this should be done a long time
ago we have so many other issues that
needs to be taken consideration as well
and i thank you for the time i wasn't i
didn't i thought it was i was going to
have more time to get prepared but
it is what it is
and i'm in favor of this bill
um house
hb 1666 right
i'm in the right place thank you very
much
and i'm sure
you don't have any question for me so
thank you for your time thank you for
listening any questions for the witness
seeing none thank you
oh i'm sorry representative
thank you mr chair
thank you ms pratt yes thank you for
taking my question um i want to thank
you for your work with gateway services
i represent nashua and i know how very
important the agency is to our uh
neighborhoods
but nashua has some public
transportation as manchester does
but i know that the majority of the
state does not can you speak to
any of the rural areas and what you know
about
members of the community that may
struggle because they are just outside
an area that has public transportation
and how uh this could be potentially
life-changing for them in terms of um
providing for their families yes that's
that's a very good point very good
question
um as a counselor we try to help we try
uh there there are many problems
transportation problems we try to solve
we try to find uh you know especially
with the school with driving the kids to
school
and with the snow with the weather if
the kid lives like a mile and a little
step away from the school the kids
doesn't get the bus
so then
the the older sibling has to go to
school to the little kid to the
elementary level
walk to school
drop off the little kid and then what
you know walk all the way across the
other away
to drop off the you know to go himself
to school
so it's many many examples many barriers
um the parents cannot drive some of the
parents don't refuse to drive some of
them have to drive without the license
because there's you know in case an
emergency
try to talk to another parents we try to
solve the problem in many ways
we tried to get a van with the pto and
and community members
so the parent that has the driver's
license could drive and pick up the kids
we try many many
um
you know ideas but the the solution is
to get the driver's license to be able
to drive safely and to be able to solve
many problems not just for the kids but
you know for older people and so forth
so
thank you for that yeah especially the
kids the individuals that i serve as
well that have the developmental
disability
it's not you know the transportation
that we have doesn't serve them well
and i do serve i am a trilingual service
coordinator so i serve individuals that
speak spanish portuguese and english
in
there this is a huge need the
transportation is besides the medicaid
let's talk about the medicaid i think
it's tomorrow morning a lot right to
include the dental hearing and a vision
so
we can talk all day thank you any other
questions any other questions
tomorrow morning we'll be here thank you
ma'am thank you so much
representative sykes i've been remiss if
i know those chairs and if you've had
back problems like i have i'm that
comfortable you can come back and sit in
your chair if you like
i absolutely
next is martin
toe
all right i promise i'll be brief
um
uh
good afternoon and
my name is marito i am a member of the
granite state organizing project and a
member of the gsop manchester chapter
i'm here in support of bill
just saying it sounds like the devil's
number but i'm sure that that's not the
case here
um
earlier i i testified about um
driver license and how it's a beautiful
thing
um
everyone in our community benefits from
it
you know i uh
i recall uh you know my my mother uh
struggled
getting her license uh we came here back
in 2003
um from ivory coast as refugees uh
and it was tough for my mom you know
coming to a new country uh she
she um she had she had to uh you know
she suffered a lot to get us to where we
are right now you know walking in the
snow
walking us to um school
and finally when she was able to get her
license you know it was it was a it was
a it was a big deal that meant uh not
having a walk
um just home after school and
and so forth
i just wanted to just um you know
end with this and and say that um
you know uh
you know new hampshire is always
we're the first and primary
but um you know we were
one of the last ones to pass you know
mlk
day and you know we don't want to be the
last i think um
uh
new hampshire can do so much more um
this law is uh is already something
that's already been passed um by
a good portion of other states so
you know
i urge you to do the you know to do the
right thing and in past
past uh one six six six god bless you
any questions for the witness
seeing none thank you
i think
francisco gulart
sorry for mispronouncing your name sir
attorney michael
good afternoon and my name is francisco
olar
i am a brazilian i live in united states
for 30 years and new hampshire for 23
years
i married my
witchy american woman i have a three
kids
two born here small born in my country
and
i'm a businessman i have a business in
nashua
over four years and
i'm here today and i ask for help
for immigrant in document for driving
lives
if he immigrant is indocumented
has drive lies
it's better for everybody because
all immigrants know
not have a drive license scary when the
police stop or cross
i have a little testimony one day about
four years ago
when they come to my house my truck
and uh
the police i i'm not good clothes and a
lot of stuff inside in
my truck police stop me and say
very hungry say
do you speak english hopefully yes
do you have a dry slice yes okay and um
when the given my drive lies my
registration the police
i give police
like this
very stupid to me
and one check my my
i have a driving license i've had all my
my documentation my my strategic car
is okay okay
go home
but i'm here today and i have another
thing
and uh
after
i don't know if you understand
my story after
civil war
my country brazil
opened the heart open the door for
and a small group of americans and
giving is a place for
start new life
and
now
big city called americana and state sao
paulo
and this now is the time for the all
people here open the heart like in my
country before the american after civil
war and they
approved for the driving lies because
immigrants
into communities is no criminal and good
people just work hard working
16 hours 20 hours a day for put the food
in the table for their family
now i ask and
and
all the people here open the heart and
sign for the drivelines for people
in documentary because it's not a
criminal
just coming here for
good life and
the second chance okay this is my
testimonial
thank you sir any questions
for this witness
seeing none thank you
welcome
yes next up i believe i saw her come in
eva castillo
good afternoon thank you chairman thank
you for
listening to
my testimony i'm sorry i was late i had
other commitments
i'm here in support of this bill uh i'm
a
manchester resident and an immigrant
rights advocate and i've been here in
this country for over 40 years
in new hampshire since 1982
part of my work
is work with
all kinds of immigrants and try to build
relationships between police and in the
immigrant communities
this bill
really
would
make
humongous progress
building trust between these two
different fractions of our society given
the lousy transportation system public
transportation system that we have in
new hampshire if we you know and i live
in manchester which is a big city and
there's basically nothing there if you
do not have a car you have no way to
bring your children to school you have
no way to do shopping you cannot work
so people need a driver's license and
this is just a reality
people are
driving right now because they do not
have
the right to get a driver's license
under our current laws
and this poses a safety threat
not only for our communities the
immigrant communities but also the
community at large for police they stop
somebody they really have no way of
knowing who's behind the wheel people
cannot find a way to register their car
so they usually have their cars
registered under somebody else's name
people cannot get
insurance car insurance for the same
reasons
so given a driver's license would
assure that
you know who you're dealing with
it would make sure that people know the
rules of the road people are
likely to stay
in the cars if there's an accident
they're not going to flee
you have to pass all kinds of tests and
everything to to to be eligible to drive
so i really don't
don't see any
um bad thing about passing
this law because people the reality is
that people are driving as far as voting
and i heard many concerns about voting
we have people here that are legal
permanent residents
for 30 40 years they have no right to
vote yet
they have driver's licenses
we know better i was here for maybe 20
25 years as a legal permanent resident
before
i was able to vote
because i had not gone to get my tests
for citizenship i work in every single
election and i never ever voted but i
motivated those that didn't have the
right to vote so we know better and and
there's already all kinds of check
lists in place to make sure that those
that are not citizen do not vote so i
just urge you to
do
something that's common sense and just
vote for this that is going to help new
hampshire and and make us all a safer
community thank you
thank you for your testimony any
questions from the committee
seeing none
thank you thank you
lydia yen
you said two minutes
yeah good
probably less
thank you for allowing me to speak um
so i came here as a refugee with my
family a single mom with five kids
and within the first few years of being
here
she was able to get a driver's license
but she barely knew any english
so she
studied very hard
and
got help from a translator
literally learned how to drive through a
translator
and through help from the community
and
the closest job she could get was like
30 to 40 minutes away from home she
couldn't find any job
closer than that before she got her
license
so
getting a license really helped and
if she
wasn't able to get one she would
probably drive illegally
because she's a single mother trying to
support five kids
so
i guess i'm here to tell you that you
should support this bill because
it will benefit
many families who are probably
in similar situations or worse
thank you
any questions
britney shoot
the os dmv
britney shoot the department does not
have any testimony at this time
thank you
no testimony no questions
the honorable neil kirk
good afternoon mr chairman
and good afternoon to members of the
committee for the record i'm neil kirk i
live in ware
and i'm representing myself
i think we all know how important
immigrants are to the united states this
country
has had immigrants who have done
extraordinary things and become citizens
and their families of course
were naturalized became citizens and are
americans i'm one of those my parents
were immigrants
that said
as you know over the past 10 15 years
we've had a flood of
undocumented or illegal immigrants into
the country in other words those people
who came here
but without the authorization of
congress for them to be here
and we just you the committee was just
told that there are 15 000 of these
folks in new hampshire
so the question is for for this
committee
how do we deal with a very difficult
situation
the bill
that you have before you 1666 is one
that i oppose
and i oppose it for three reasons
um
first
the effect of this bill
sections one two and five
is to make new hampshire an
immigration sanctuary state
that's what this bill does
it does it in two ways
first as you've heard
it allows
undocumented or illegal immigrants to
get driver's licenses something they
cannot currently do
and secondly it either denies or makes
it extremely difficult for federal
authorities to have access to new
hampshire drivers records in immigration
cases indeed it criminalizes their
behavior if they access this for those
purposes
a violation being a class b
misdemeanor
so for those two reasons
we see that there is a
an effort on the part of this bill to
create as i say a sanctuary state for
illegal undocumented immigrants in new
hampshire
second reason i oppose the bill
is that
the bill changes current law
to make a driver's license a legal
identity document current law says a
driver's license is only permission to
operate on the roads of the motor
vehicle on the roads but this document
changes that and adds
a driver's license is a legal
identification documents
i don't understand the significance of
that
and i hope the committee will get the ag
to come in and explain that
for example
this may make it easier for immigrants
to prove who they are in a legal way
but it also may promote a papers please
society
when the
police or law enforcement ask people for
documentation and require them to
produce a driver's license which now is
an identity document under this bill
i don't know if that's a good thing or a
bad thing but i am very concerned about
it and it's not clear from the bill what
the consequences are
the third reason has to do with social
security numbers
the languages is somewhat
unclear but basically
the bill coerces an applicant for a
non-real
id license into providing their social
security numbers
or pay an extra 100 dollars
fifty dollars for the license a hundred
dollars for the
ability to remove your social security
number uh from the department's database
this doesn't apply to a real id license
under federal law you have to provide
your social security number for that and
the state dmv has to keep that number
under current law
a person who is applying for the license
for the first time has to provide a
social security number but at his option
may have it removed from the
department's records the department
needs that to validate a variety of
things but they don't need to keep it on
record and under current law a person
doesn't have to
give permission to do it under this bill
if you want to exercise that right it
cost you a hundred dollars
the bill seems to be drafted so that it
only applies to first time
license applicants and not
to renewal applicants
it's not clear it's confusing
and
that needs to be addressed although
frankly i think the idea of charging so
much money uh to keep your information
out of the
dmv database is
inappropriate
specifically
section 7 which provides for the 100
may be viewed not as a fee but as a tax
and is therefore unconstitutional
in new hampshire a fee can only be equal
to the cost of providing the service
plus 25 percent that's new hampshire
supreme court's definition
the committee needs to check with dmv to
find out whether that hundred dollars
meets that criteria i don't believe it
does
secondly
requiring a person to provide a social
security number to get a non-real id
license
absent to substantial justification
is contrary to and probably in violation
of the reasonably enact the recently
enacted constitutional amendment
article 2b
says
this is called a right to privacy an
individual's right to live free from
governmental intrusion in private or
personal information is natural
essential and inherent
now
the bill seems to say one can buy his
way
his or her way out of information
sharing with the government
by paying for it
this suggests to me at least that
there's no compelling reason
for the government to have that social
security number
and if that's the case
i think it's a violation of
our constitution article amendment 2b
for these three reasons i would ask the
committee find the bill inexpedient to
legislate thank you mr chairman
thank you for your testimony any
questions from members of the committee
representative talersky
i'm going to take a stab at something
good afternoon thank you for taking my
question
um
your history here uh in transportation
has come up quite a bit in my uh one and
a half terms and it's nice to finally
meet you
um i understand that you've always been
a proponent of
the right to privacy
for people who live here in new
hampshire
that's correct
and um i am curious though as you said
that part of the parts of this bill that
you disagree with
is that um
the records were to be kept from federal
authorities and i'm wondering why
that view of people's right to privacy
would not apply to this group of
individuals that would benefit from this
bill
the federal government has established a
policy with respect to immigration
the federal government has authorized
its agents to enforce that policy
that establishes
a
justification we can debate whether it's
compelling or not for the federal
government have access for this
information for new hampshire to stand
in the way of the federal government
getting this information to enforce its
laws
seems to me to be contrary to the nature
of a federal republic
were there no federal immigration laws
i certainly would agree with you that
this information should not be made
available to federal authorities
but considering that there are i think
it's inappropriate for us to deny the
federal government the information it
needs to enforce its laws and remember
the federal government
is under the constitution of the united
states the supreme law of the land
and i'm a law-abiding citizen i guess
i'll leave it thank you very much
thank you for that question by the way
very thoughtful
representative horrigan
i'll just clarify
point one which you said
sections one two and five would make new
hampshire an immigration sanctuary state
so but why is that a bad thing i mean
i'm old enough to remember when
we welcome
millions of uh
immigrants from uh from europe who are
fleeing oppression either communists or
fascists or even just
fleeing the social uh
chaos to follow world war ii so why is
that a bad thing now
thank you for that question
representative horgan um
it's not a bad thing
the problem is that there are different
kinds of immigrants to the united states
some of them are here legally and as i
said in my introductory statement
i heartily support that this country
needs immigrants for population growth
for brains for talents goodness knows
what
and i would hope the federal government
would be passing policies to encourage
those folks to come here
but if you have an immigration law at
the federal level
it's got to be enforced and we may not
like it we may want to change it in
which case we should do that but until
that happens
we need to make sure that
those people who are not here in
accordance with those laws
do not get the benefits that those
people who here are here immigrants who
are here in accordance with those laws
get i see two distinct categories here
thanks thank you representative schultz
thank you mr chair
it is great to see you i've admired when
you served in this body how fiercely you
fought for privacy i think that you um
i admire you for that and it's good to
see you again
um i hope i'm asking this question in a
way that is germane but
since you've raised the issue of
who has documented status and who
doesn't
you must know that the need for
immigrant workers now
is far outpacing the number of available
visas and while that's a federal
issue that needs to be rectified you you
must know
that there are businesses in new
hampshire that
really desperately need the help because
american citizens aren't
working in those jobs currently or don't
want to work in those jobs
i'm sorry i didn't get the question
in raising this you made a
very clear point about the distinction
between people who are currently not
documented
through work visas or tourist visas or
as a citizen
which obviously is an important point
that this bill addresses
but you must also understand
given your understanding of the free
market suspend please suspend plea
please just ask a question
no just ask it in a question please
thank you mr chair i just am aware he is
a fierce
fighter for the free market and our
market desperately needs workers when we
don't have enough visas
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative schultz i do understand
the question and it is complicated
this is the state legislature
i recognize that in the free market
things happen
illegals are hired there's a great need
for all sorts of not just
farm workers
but all sorts of workers we have what
2.6 unemployment rate
businesses
they don't advertise hamburgers anymore
they advertise help wanted
we understand that the question for the
legislature is
do we act to facilitate
illegal undocumented
immigrants
to work in this state
contrary to federal law and i think
while a business may or may not want to
skirt the law i don't think it's
appropriate for the legislature to do
that
to facilitate that
but i i do appreciate your
your concerns and i share them and as i
said at the beginning i think this
country needs to adopt a much more
comprehensive
immigration policy so that
both temporary and permanent workers can
come from abroad i mean in our
competition with russia and china and
all of the other countries brain power
is crucial we have an opportunity this
is a magnet country for all sorts of
people and why we're not taking
advantage of it
you ought to run for congress let's put
it that way
thank you anyone else
seeing none thank you thank you mr
chairman
anybody else who wished to speak
and has not had the opportunity
don't forget if you want to sign up
either in for or against this house bill
you can use the blue sheet that's there
okay seeing no one else i close hearing
on 1666 fn
i think he should
oh
i can't dance
foreign
what's that
sheesh
oh
thank you
whatever
is
stay on the line
yes
it's nice to see you
foreign
thank you
oh
movement
chief
is it yours too right yep
thank you
all right welcome everybody
excuse me gentlemen
i'm going to open up the public hearing
on house bill 1093.
uh
excuse me
relative to the license share of
non-resident aliens temporarily residing
in new hampshire
chair recognizes
the prime sponsor
representative sykes
thank you chairman walsh thank you
members of the transportation committee
for allowing me to give this
opening testimony
for the record i am representative
george sykes i serve the grafton 13
which is the city of lebanon
this bill is
part of a suite of bills that you've
seen that i've been introducing
all of them are trying to fix a certain
problem that may exist
a problem that
isn't easily fixable sometimes and
sometimes it's pretty easy in this
particular bill
i spent some time with the former
director of the dmv and this was the
language that we came up with but
unfortunately um the bill
never made it through the covid process
so it was not there was never a vote on
this bill in the past but this is the
same bill that i've introduced before
its purpose is pretty straightforward
and also quite limited
um
a little bit of background for those of
you who are struggling to keep up with
all these
twists and turns about immigration law
a person can come into this country
legally
as an example on a tourist permit
but they came here on that on this
tourist permit a tourist visa
because of
violence in their country for instance
and that they could escape they came
here they were here in the united states
legally their next step
is to apply for asylum to get achieve
permanent status here
whilst waiting for that they have no way
to drive because they are a temporary
resident and you can't get a driver's
license if you're a temporary resident
in new hampshire
there's
so what happens is when they put in
their asylum request
they're still ineligible to apply to get
a driver's license
however
one of the federal rules under the
immigration laws
is that
if you do not receive your hearing
after one year
then you can get a work permit
that status then allows you to apply for
a driver's license here in new hampshire
if you have a work permit
the disconnect that this bill is
attempting to fix
is that
they arrive
they
file their asylum status request
and then they have to wait for a whole
year before they can
actually apply for a driver's license in
rural northern new hampshire
think about it
that's a problem
it's really really difficult so
the language was worked out with dmv
last year um it's just attempting to
give them a temporary driver's license
while they wait for adjudication on
their permanent status
excuse me while they wait to receive
their
work permit which they can then go in
and take the driver's test both written
and practical and they can drive legally
in new hampshire this they're here
legally
there's a legal process for them to get
their driver's license but they have to
wait one year
the problem also applies to the fact
that
you've heard some conflicting
information about
asylum requests i can speak from
personal knowledge that a person that i
um helped sponsor through
um escaping his country due to violence
who now lives in lebanon works in
lebanon and now drives in lebanon he is
at year seven waiting for his
asylum requests to be heard
so that's why we try to
make their entryway to getting driving
privileges a little faster within a
system that dmv
has in the past been supportive of
and if i'm certainly happy to take any
questions
thank you
any questions from the committee
representative hill
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my question representative
is this legislation of yours
based on
any legislation from
from another country perhaps if if one
of those asylum seekers had chosen a
country other than the united states
would they have that ability
to get a temporary driver's license and
uh and operate in in that country as
well well i'm not sure that i'm
qualified to know
uh a full and complete answer for that
representative hill what i can tell you
is that the bill that's before you
was a specific for
new hampshire
just trying to fix the problem for
asylum seekers who
choose for whatever reason to come and
live here in new hampshire
thank you but i'm i'm wondering if if um
when you submitted the
the bill to
ols whether that was
as a result of or
included in language that came from some
other place that was that this type of
operation had been
had been approved
is this possible in another country i
guess
yeah i don't i don't have an answer to
that it was i i did not consult with any
other jurisdictions again this was i was
looking for a new hampshire specific
fix to a problem
although it's very narrow in scope that
it's not like we have thousands of
asylum seekers but we do have some
and they have difficulty getting their
driver's license in a timely manner so
this was a temporary solution for them
until they can then apply for a
permanent driver's license after
receiving their work permit
thank you for your answer
any other questions from the committee
representative talersky
thank you mr chairman thank you for
taking my question representative sykes
um
following your timeline of someone
applies they get a hearing within a year
they can then uh apply for driver's
license the 180 days
um
that the driver's license can be valid
that's six months so i guess i'm just
curious
where in the process
does that 180 days
start or how did that number come about
if you could help me understand that so
format i'm going to have to name names
here
former director
bilecki
and i came to the realization that
the license need only be good for 180
days because that's approximately the
time it would take
once they were eligible to get this
temporary license
that would be the time it would take
before they could get there
once they had it would take for them to
get a work permit and move on
so there's there's like i said it's just
it's a narrow window of time that we're
trying to fix hence the reason it's
temporary for that time frame
any other questions from the committee
representative hill
thank you mr chairman and thank you for
taking my additional question
um when they submit for a temporary
driver's license
is does that require a social security
number i don't i don't believe it does
um
but i'm not i i have to beg off to the
dmv about that i think the
the question would be more accurately
representative i think
is can you get a social security number
before you have a work permit
i don't know the answer to that
right well and do you need
a social security number to get the work
from it
again i don't have the answer to that
i i just would like
and i appreciate your question thank you
i what i'm really trying to focus on
here is just a very narrow problem
and that is driving privileges for for a
very discreet group of
individuals
for a very discreet length of time until
they can then fulfill
the requirements for a a full
privileged driver's license
um you mentioned that so i have a
question you said it's a very narrow
issue and it may be
but this is relative can you say you
have experience in this
who is eligible to seek asylum and under
what circumstances
in general without getting too deep in
the weeds because
in the reading i've done on the into the
immigration laws and we're not debating
those here it doesn't seem to be that
narrow
i don't have an answer for that i would
prefer to have an immigration
some other immigration official answer
that question
um
when i had my conversations with dmv
there was a very small number i don't
unfortunately it was last year and i've
been looking for my notes but it was a
very small number of
individuals thank you state
representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you
representative sykes for taking my
question
is the concept of this if if someone
gets a temporary license for 180 days is
this
kind of the stepping stone to getting a
full-fledged
license i guess i'll call it
well before the yeah the
one it's partly it's a public safety
issue okay partly and i guess i would
elaborate a little further
and i stand to be corrected about this
but when you
when you
choose to move into new hampshire you
have a there's a time frame when you
have to apply for a driver's license if
you're driving
now prior to that they could be using
their the driver's license
from another jurisdiction
that creates
problems in and of itself in terms of
making
is this driver license the same thing as
what you know are you driving a tractor
trailer when you really only should be
driving a car
so those kinds of questions could come
up we could have translation issues
all of those things can be
problematic however
you are legally allowed to drive under
your
for the sake of discussion your haitian
driver's license
which is in french
and may or may not be
extreme it may not be particularly
equivalent
under this you would
still have to take the driver's test
both written and practical
and you would get
a temporary license identifying it as
such that it is temporary
until you get your work permit if for
some the reason for the
length of time
if you don't go and get a work permit
based on your asylum request
then you that driving privilege goes
away
that's the reason for it being temporary
if you do get your work permit you can
take the next step and get a driver's
license
any other questions from the committee
cnn thank you
next up chad recognizes grace kendecki
from the american friends service
committee
in support of the bill
no questions
are we on good
hello and thank you again for taking my
testimony just to clarify my name is
grace candecke i know there's a lot of
e's in my name but they all sound like
a's um so thank you again committee
members for taking my testimony
i am the program coordinator with
american friends service committee and i
bring testimony on behalf of the new
hampshire immigrant rights network which
is a coalition of new hampshire
organizations that work with and within
immigrant communities in new hampshire
including asylum seekers so just to
quickly clarify before i go into my
testimony and i will paraphrase once
again and i'll provide copies to the
committee um is that in order to um the
order of operations is that you do need
to apply for a work permit first um
before you get your social security
number
and in order to people who apply for
asylum apply for asylum based on
credible fear of persecution because
their life would be in danger due to
their political or religious beliefs or
their affiliation with a particular
marginalized group based on nationality
race or gender so there are particular
categories as to why people do seek
asylum
and the last data does show that um in
the last set of from 2019 my colleagues
did share with me we had about 27 000 um
asylum petitions granted in new
hampshire
so
i want to go into why this bill we are
seeking support for hb 1093
we are
asking the committee to please um to
pass this bill in order to diminish the
waiting period for
residents of new hampshire who are
seeking asylum in order for them to be
able to be issued a temporary driver's
license
as many of us many of folks have heard
and continue to learn about our
immigration system are the work permit
and
work permit and adjudications are
backlogged with significant delays and
this has significant impact on
communities
and families of asylum seekers in new
hampshire
this means that even after waiting a
year to apply for permission to work um
it could still take a year another year
or more um in in order for that work
permit to be issued and with that work
authorization most asylum seekers again
would not be able to
be able to get their social security
number um be able to provide for their
families and do what they need to do so
as i know we continue to hear that new
hampshire is a state that is very
difficult to live in if you're not able
to be able to drive
during this bill would allow
petitioners to be able to obtain a
driver's license and they would they
would also
um i apologize i lost my place
it would add an eligible eligibility
class to that would allow people to be
able to get their driver's licenses so i
do urge the committee to please pass hb
1093 because it does in fact serve the
residents of new hampshire and does
indeed close a significant gap that has
been described here in our state thank
you happy to take questions
thank you very much any questions from
the committee
representative i'll be very quick i just
wanted to clarify and maybe see if i was
misunderstanding the speaker about a
piece of information she included she
said 27 000 asylum seekers which i just
googled because it seems like a lot
and i'm on the dhhs new hampshire.gov
website the health of human services
and it appears that it looks like
the most recent information is from 2019
that there were 400 total refugees
the year before that 393 total refugees
so is it possible that that 27 000 is a
total since a certain year back
oh yeah you're i'm probably right i
would have to double check with my
colleagues
sorry
oh i apologize the number is for
countrywide that
that
and yes refugees are a different
category from asylum seekers but i do
apologize for that misunderstanding it
is countrywide not specific to new
hampshire
thanks for that clarification i
apologize to the chair first thank you
for catching that
any other questions from the committee
cnn thank you very much thank you
chair recognizes jeff overdank from the
department of motor vehicles
good afternoon mr chairman and members
of the committee for the record my name
is jeff overnight and i'm here to
represent the division of motor vehicles
and opposition in this bill today
in very similar fashion to the way i
testified on an earlier bill for the
same reasons that
there is a process that one goes through
when you apply for a driver license
let's say you're moving in from another
state you come into the counter you fill
out the application you provide a driver
license to us as proof that you've got a
license in another state
we immediately do some data entry while
you're standing there and we go out to
that other state and says
does this person have the ability to
drive and is a license in good standing
and that answer comes back immediately
and that gives us the authority the
ability to go out and make sure that
you're qualified to drive
secondly if you were to provide your
social security card to us as you are to
answer the earlier question from the
representative it is a requirement to
provide your social security number on
your first
driver license application that is found
in section 263 of the motor vehicle code
we then run that social security number
through our system we go right out to
social security and it comes back and
tells us whether or not that's your card
and if it's a valid number
and in the same fashion and has provided
an earlier testimony on an earlier bill
we have the same
instant link up with
department of homeland security specific
uscis customs immigration
and when you provide us documentation
from immigration we immediately go out
with that information that you provided
us on the application and any documents
you may have handed to us
and we send an immediate answer
immediate require a query out to uscis
and we say is this a valid card this is
a valid status
and based on our interpretation of 263
39a as it's written is that that status
is to be verified before you issue a
driver license or non-driver
identification card
and in the event you've just applied or
just provided an application to
immigration for status we will not
receive a response
we will not receive a response to our
system
until they're determined to be approved
so what you're asking for us to do is
verify some documents in this bill and
not verify others
having said that i'll take any questions
you may have
thank you sir any questions from the
committee
representative
thank you thank you for taking my
question
are you aware of
anything that an asylum seeker would
have
that would demonstrate that they had
filed a complete application do they
have a receipt that they have a
confirmation
anything that could work to prove that
they have gone through the process the
legal process as it is outlined
we receive confirmation in the fact that
they may bring in a receipt that they
paid for an application
but it doesn't indicate approval of that
application
follow-up
follow-up sorry
but isn't that the point of this bill is
um
it's not for people who have an approved
application it's people who have a
pending application so if they've
applied then in fact it is pending
that's my understanding of the bill
that's correct
and if not i can add on that for you um
not all of them get approved either so
just the mere fact of applying for it uh
doesn't mean they're going to get it if
you go into the immigration laws it's
called frivolous they actually use the
word so
and i don't that helps well but that's
why it's a temporary license right
thank you any other questions from the
committee
cnn thank you very much thank you
uh that is last person i have signed up
to speak on house bill
1093 i'll ask
one more time if there's anybody here
that wishes to
seeing none i'm going to close the
public hearing on house bill 1093
we have executive sessions scheduled for
three o'clock
uh we will do our very best to start
promptly uh
we may need a couple extra minutes to
prepare
um chances are very unlikely we're going
to execute any of the three bills we
just heard this afternoon were late this
morning and this afternoon so
thank you we'll see you soon
all right sorry for the delay everybody
welcome back
at this time
uh as scheduled i'm going to open up the
executive session on house bill 1100
and the chair recognizes representative
gorsky for a motion
thank you mr chairman um i'd like to
make a motion to itl hb 1100. it'll has
been moved there's our second
representative seconded by
representative greg i mean i he'll
would you care to speak to your motion
yes thank you mr chairman um as was
discussed this law was changed several
years ago after an incident where
someone was pulled over for
not having a license was written up
and soon thereafter plowed into a series
of bicycles
causing
causing damage
to various people and
i sense that doing this is
a slippery slope
and by changing this violation moving it
from a misdemeanor to a violation is a
dangerous uh precedent and a slippery
slope so therefore i think we should
vote to itl 1100.
thank you representative anybody else
care to speak to 1100
representative sykes
thank you mr chairman
so i have a slightly
different perspective about house bill
shocker i know
i i understand that there were some
original motor motivations to pat to
change that bill back in i think 2015
and i respect that concern however
when we pass laws we we really need to
be mindful
mindful of
who it affects and how many people it
affects
eleven hundred is trying to make it
possible for
um
single working parents
others who are are economically
challenged we're trying to make the
penalty to the penalty there fit their
the the crime if you will and far more a
far greater number of people
are affected by having
this be a misdemeanor than a violation
than a one-off
incident that happened
years ago
and so no disrespect about
all the people who are affected by that
one-off incident but we really we really
need to be
cognizant of the fact that we're but
this will help
people who can use our help
and so
i would urge uh
to
vote no on this particular motion so
another one could be introduced
further comments from the committee
representative palersky i just wanted to
make one comment of something that came
up um i'm not sure it fully came out in
the hearing but
one concern i had was thinking about
maybe teenagers going for a joyride
we've all known that they've done it a
15 year old takes mom's car or someone
who hasn't you know finished driver's ed
um and
i'm concerned about what that means for
college applications applying for the
military that kind of thing and um it's
a lot for a teenager and i i just i'm
just throwing that out there as trying
to think of who else this could affect
but i i thank you for the time
i don't i don't know if anyone could
answer this but
if that situation that representative
tuliski was talking about i'm looking at
the lieutenant back there
i know
is it at the discretion of the police
officer if they should catch that person
that that teenager going for a joyride
is it
is it your discretion to say hey this is
you don't have to
write them up it's not a must or a shall
thank you very much
sure representative sykes i appreciate
your i didn't i waited a week just to
hear from you
[Laughter]
um i've asked the trooper
discretion to write something other than
or just discretion to not write at all
in other words could he write it as a
violation
or does it have to be a misdemeanor if
he writes
a ticket
thank you thank you
for the comments from
representative smith
thank you mr chair um a little more
focused version of that question if
you've stopped the person
it's not
likely that they only did the one thing
wrong not having a license
so if they've had multiple violations
could you choose which ones to write up
thank you for the comments from the
committee
seeing none i was going to chime in but
i don't see the need at this point
um i think enough's been said
i'll ask the clerk to call the roll when
she's ready the motion on the floor is
inexpedient to legislate on house bill
vice chairman gaggy
yes
representative smith
clerk votes yes representative hill yes
representative thompson yes
representative ankerberg yes
representative gorski
yes representative o'hare yes
representative teresa yes representative
sykes
no
representative horrigan no
representative fenton
representative rambo
no representative rich no
representative talersky no
representative fox no representative
schultz
no representative
no chairman walsh
yes
ten two
one two three four five six seven nine
okay so the committee
um
the committee recommendation of itl has
adopted 10 to 9. uh obviously this is
going to go on the regular calendar i'm
going to close the executive session on
house bill 1100
give us a few minutes to reset thank you
chairman i will we will offer a minority
uh report
probably by me
do you uh have you decide who's going to
write the uh minority report
probably
so i'll put it down for as you then
well
no i can't think of any better person
but i want to make it official before i
use ink
so
yes
uh okay i'm going to open up the
executive session on house bill 1208
that is relative to driver education
the chair recognizes representative
talersky for a motion thank you mr
chairman i'd like to make a motion of
itl on house bill 1208
ital on 1208 has been moved is there a
second
seconded by representative fenton care
to speak your motion
sure
um
i think we've all with the exception of
our new members um heard a lot of
testimony about this topic in the past
um
i think that uh
probably the most
significant new piece of information
that we received this year though
um
was the
study presented by dan goodman of triple
a
of the
uh texas an analysis of the texas parent
education
driving education program which showed
that
accidents increased the severity of the
accidents increased
and they're involved
students who get their driver's license
in this program were involved in nearly
50 percent more crashes
with more severe injury
so that is the first amount of data that
showed me that there are problems uh
with moving away from our teen safety
driving program
and with that i will uh leave it and i
hope you can support me on the itl
motion
thank you any other comments from the
committee
well
i'm super very surprised okay
um we'll speed it right up seeing no
other comments i'll ask the clerk to
call a roll when she's ready the motion
on the floor is itl on house bill 1208.
represent vice chairman vagney
yes
representative smith
clerk votes yes representative hill no
representative thompson
yes
representative ankerberg
no
representative gorski
representative o'hara
representative torreson no
representative sykes
yes
representative horrigan yes
representative fenton yes
representative rambo yes
representative rich yes
representative talersky yes
representative fox yes
representative schultz yes
representative vayu
yes
and chairman walsh
14 to 5.
uh committee recommendation of itl and
house bill 1208 is adopted 14-5
uh also on regular calendar i'll close
the executive session on house bill 1208
give us a few minutes to reset thank you
are you doing it
okay he needs a name that's all yeah so
he can do the chasing
who's doing it
representative
i'm ready anytime you are
okay i'm gonna open up the executive
session on house bill 1464.
excuse me
the clerk's ready and i'm
not just looking for the title
establishing a committee to study the
feasibility and implementation of
furthering electrical vehicle adoption
in new hampshire chair recognizes
representative fenton for a motion
thank you mr chair i move interim study
of hb 1464. interim study has been moved
is there a second representative o'hara
seconds care to speak to motion
uh yes thank you mr chair um i think
there is some interest in this bill
especially when we're talking about
representative gagne's transportation
council and the need
for evs in new hampshire and however
there's kind of some roadblocks to get
these especially considering the other
states around us and i think
interim study could help with some
creative solutions to this problem
fair enough thank you any other
discussion
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the role
when she's ready the motion on the floor
is interim study on house bill 1464.
vice chairman gagne
yes
representative smith yes
clerk votes yes representative hill yes
representative thompson yes
representative ankenberg yes
representative gorski yes representative
o'hara yes representative toroshan yes
representative sykes
representative horrigan
yes representative fenton yes
representative rambo yes
representative rich yes representative
yes representative fox
yes representative schultz yes
representative
yes and chairman walsh yes okay
okay the committee recommendation of
interim study on 1464 is adopted 19 to
0.
his consent's been moved in second
seconded by travis i mean representative
o'hara
without objection consent it'll go
consent that is i'll close the executive
session on house bill 1464.
i'm all ready
okay at this time i'm going to open up
the executive session on house bill
1445.
to get the language exact
relative to the identification of police
vehicles
chair recognizes representative o'hara
for a motion
thank you mr chairman i motion in terms
study for this spill interim study has
been moved is there a second
seconded by representative gagne care to
speak your motion
uh yes thank you mr chairman there's
just a little bit of wording that needs
to get figured out between the sponsor
and the amendments and there's been
support from the senators on this bill
so i'm hoping to bring it back
with a better version
thank you any further discussion
cnn i'll ask the clerk to call the roll
when she's ready motion on the floor is
in room steady on 14 45.
uh
vice chairman gagne
yes
representative smith yes
clerk votes yes representative hill yes
representative thompson yes
representative ankerberg yes
representative gorski yes representative
o'hare yes representation
yes representative sykes
yes
representative horrigan
representative fenton yes
representative rambo
yes representative rich yes
representative talarsky
yes
representative fox
representative schultz yes
representative
yes
chairman walsh yes okay 19-0
zero 19-0 okay
all right so the uh
yeah the committee recommendation of
interim study
is adopted 19-0 i heard a motion for
consent who seconded it
represent thompson uh with no objections
it'll go on consent
seeing none i'll close the executive
session on house bill 1445.
okay at this time
i'm going to open up the
executive session on house bill 1492.
again i gotta remember to get ahead of
this
relative to decal plates for the new
hampshire council on the arts chair
recognizes representative o'hara for a
motion thank you mr chairman of motion
itl on house bill 1492.
okay
it'll's the motion uh representative
gagne seconds and care to speak your
motion
uh yeah thank you mr chairman i just um
this is
not one of the five of c3s right sorry
it's not one of the bible's e3's
so we're just opening up a i know we
opened up with the firefighters but i
think this would open door wider for
more
councils and i think it's a bad hole to
go down
okay fair enough any further discussion
representative tillerson thank you
um
i like the idea of this
i understand that
having a state department as part of
this program
would be relatively new um but
i will support the itl
primarily because of what we discussed
this morning about the
[Music]
financial investment that a group must
make to participate in the program that
is often not understood
understanding the demand that may or may
not be existing for a program such as
this
and
partially because i think of
misunderstanding of what the program is
and so
with that um
i will support the itl and also
uh move forward to try to help the
[Music]
prime sponsor
in the future if she wants to find a way
to um honor the arts in such a way
eloquently put representative o'hare
thank you just a quick question should
this be something that we start looking
into more as a committee
the fiscal
the financial impact of this for these
councils and like start i telling them
if we feel that they couldn't make it
i i'm just it's a question in general
off of what she said
we
with what we got from information from
the other bill
i think it's going to be a question on
every one of these we see from here on
and
whether it was intentional or not i
think it's here
so any other discussion on
seeing none i'll ask the clerk to call
the roll
when she's ready uh the motion on the
floor is itl on hospital 1492.
vice chairman gagne
yes
representative smith yes
clerk votes yes representative hill yes
representative thompson yes
representative ankerberg yes
representative gorski yes representative
o'hare yes representative torreson yes
representative sykes
yes representative horrigan yes
representative fenton yes representative
rambo yes representative rich yes
representative talersky yes
representative fox yes representative
schultz yes representative
yes chairman walsh yes
19-0 committee recommended
recommendation has adopted consent's
been moved and seconded any objection to
consent seeing none consent that is i'll
close the exact session on
where was i 1492.
and hang tight for a minute we i'm going
to look at our list we might be able to
do a couple more that we heard today
it won't be the big ones at the end
don't worry
but there are a couple others i may
decide to move on excuse me give me a
couple of minutes to consider
okay
i'm not going to uh
um exec anymore today
we did eight plus a reconsideration so
we've done our work
um just to give you a little game plan
of where i was hoping to go it might
change a little bit now
um
so we scheduled today we've done a good
job executing as we go
next tuesday i'm going to schedule
another full day with an exact session
we get caught up on these
i
at this time not intending on scheduling
anything for the week of the 15th
because we're going to be in session for
two days and two days is enough for most
people
and then the 22nd i've reserved the haul
originally it was going to be for the
two remaining bills that we don't cover
next week
with
hp 1000 and hb 1424 which i'm expecting
could be a crowd that's the speed limit
on winnipesaukee
followed by an executive session
my goal is to get everything wrapped up
by the end of february 22nd that's the
goal
if we run if we run into any snags we do
have time but that's that's where i want
to head
so
any questions
mr chairman just a reminder just a
reminder that committee members that in
the office there's the new book
it's not this color it's another color
yeah if you look
if you look in the desk in there there's
two boxes they are purple this year
they're unmistakable
so if there's no other questions i'll
thank everybody for a good day's work
and we'll see you next week
you